e
all right so um I'm going to call uh the
first uh meeting of the Judiciary
Committee in this new session to order
and first would you please stand and
allegiance conratulations to the flag
United States
America
stands so I want to um welcome everyone
to uh uh the new uh session year and to
the Judiciary Committee um I guess what
I'd like to do first um and I and I know
this will be because for the returning
members this will be kind of old hat
you've heard it you've heard it all
before but I think it would be helpful
for the new members and maybe you know
as a as a uh just a little refresher for
all of us um since uh some of us are
getting a little bit advanced in years
and you know we might have a senior
moment from time to time
so uh so what I what I'm uh gonna ask us
to do first is uh for everyone to tell
us who you are and sort of why you're
here that is why you decided on the
Judiciary Committee and um I'll start
and then I'll ask the vice chair and the
ranking member to go next and from that
after that we'll kind of go around the
room um so my name is Bob Lynn I'm a
representative from Windam this is my
third term um I'm I'm a republican uh in
terms of why I'm I'm here um I have some
interest in things uh dealing with the
Judiciary in particular since I spent a
fair amount of time as a judge um in New
Hampshire um in terms of my my interests
um this uh this year um a lot of the
things that I'm interested in and bills
that I have drafted I've proposed bills
on are actually not before the Judiciary
Committee I have a couple of things that
I think are pretty important before um
election law I have uh one or two that I
think are going to go to um education
and then I do have some here um
including uh one dealing with um end of
life options that I know representative
Smith is a co-sponsor on um and there
are some other ones uh that I have here
some dealing with the right to no law
there uh that are designed to uh um
correct areas that I think need to be
corrected in the right to no law as some
of you may know particularly the people
are here we uh or last time we had a
number of right to know bills last time
I think we made some uh pretty good
progress but there's some stuff yet to
be done um so that's that's it for me
representative man thank
you uh representative Dennis Manion from
Salem uh this is my second term and I
was asked uh earlier this year if I
would come over here and be Vice chair I
came over from Criminal Justice and
Public Safety uh I did 30 years in law
enforcement eight of those years as a
police prosecutor not a lawyer just a
twoe course and you go prosecute crimes
um some of my interests here mostly
criminal justice related so I filed a
few bills that I'm going to go through
that committee on assaulting police
officers and false reports and um
another one on being able to get
Firearms back quicker uh if they're
taken for uh by the court for any reason
restraining order or communal B
protective order I guess it's quite a
long time before you you're able to have
a firearm back but you're not able to
the court doesn't move quick enough so
so those are some of the bills that I
have filed um I guess that's about it
for me and I I I hope my experience
helps in this committee there are some
areas I'm not experiencing but there are
some that I am that's it thank you
representative Smith thank you very much
and welcome to the Judiciary Committee
my name is mar Smith this is my 14th
term I'm looking around and I'd like to
say that I began before many of you were
born and I think it's only one of you
who wasn't born in
1996 no no I was too oh all right well
I'm glad that's why I can accept your
judgments so representative Alexander um
my time in the legislature has been Divi
divided between uh finance and
Judiciary and you will see that you can
take the girl off Finance but you can't
take Finance out of the girl because I
frequently pay attention to those
issues um in terms of bills that I filed
personally I don't think that's really
necessary to talk about here what I want
to talk about is that this is a very
very important committee it um it deals
with significant life and death issues
and it also deals with what I think of
as core principles of what at least used
to be the state of New Hampshire
philosophy and that is the importance of
personal privacy and the importance of
accountability um as we see it through
right to know so those are issues that I
care about completely um I
am uh
nonpartisan I'm a Democrat I've been a
Democrat but in terms of my function in
the committee it is
nonpartisan and I look to learn a lot
from all of my colleagues Democrat and
Republican so that together we can get
as close as we can to move
ourselves forward and um and I'm really
glad to work with my old friends and
people who will now be my new friends
thank
you thank you um representative Morton I
guess we'll we'll then we'll go sort of
go around this way sure uh
representative Morton uh from Jonathan
Morton from
Manchester um I got involved in this uh
the ju Judiciary Committee um because
you know I believe that we are a country
of Law and Order and at the same time
we're a country of freedom and there has
to be a great balance between those two
things um and I do have as well a number
of family and friends that have either
currently or were at one time in law
enforcement I'm actually one of the
people that helped start the Comfort dog
program for um the police departments in
the state and um that's that's that's
about it learn terrific thank you
representative Horan um so my name is
Timothy Horgan like represent Smith I'm
from straford County District 10 which
is the town of Durham and um I've been
on this committee this is my seventh
term and then there's an eighth termiz
on a committee that doesn't exist
anymore which kind of overlapped the
work of this committee so um I guess I I
guess I came back because I want to
preserve you know the rule of law and
our personal personal freedoms so I may
um and I have hav I don't think any of
the bills I've introduced sponsored or
co-sponsor will end up in this committee
but I
did uh sponsor a perennial bill which is
now over from the new housing committee
one of the many perennial landlord
tenant bills that come back year after
year so I'll be seeing actually repr
Alexander over there over there because
he's has a dual role he's on that
committee too so we um and um so even
though we don't have those landlord
tenant bills to do anymore I'm sure our
work will expand fill the uh time
available to do it so that hopefully
I'll mostly look forward to doing it so
thanks no actually you said just before
I get to representative trip just so you
know as I mentioned in the email we are
going to be hearing a presentation from
Chief Justice McDonald and uh miss krian
the legal council for the judicial
branch they're doing criminal justice
right now as I understand it and so they
said they would get here as soon as they
can so when they get here I will
probably interrupt wherever we are so so
we can hear from them representative
trip
uh good morning uh my name is Richard
trip I am from
dairy this is my fourth term my second
term in
judiciary uh I got here as soon as I
could I spent probably 20 years uh
serving on various Municipal boards but
uh I think that gives me a little
perspective on uh you know what uh
what's good and bad in our our towns and
cities so uh
but uh I'm happy to be here and happy to
uh see everyone again thank you thank
you representative Manos thank you uh
I'm Zoe Manos from stratum which is near
Portsmouth um I'm an attorney I'm in my
second term and I'm an attorney and so I
love this committee and I think everyone
will find it's very collegial we have
strong differences of opinion but we
operated last term very collegially and
I I think we will this term also um
issues that are important to me are
domestic violence is extremely important
to me and the um death With Dignity bill
is also very very important to me so I
look forward to working on those issues
and other issues with the committee
thank you thank you representative Perez
my name is Christine Perez I am from
londondary New Hampshire the same place
that our speaker of the house is from
and the same place that our head of the
Senate is from um
I this is my second term I was put on
Judiciary shocked to be put on Judiciary
in my first term somebody said I was
meant to be there and I think I was and
I'm thrilled to be back again I was put
here by parents um children and parents
are a big stride of mine and I also am a
staunch um believer in um the first the
second amendment and I did put in some
bills for education I put in a bill I
put in several bills that um
constituents had asked for so um none
for here though oh well I'm a co-sponsor
on one to hear from this morning and
unfortunately I don't think the sponsor
will be here because his wife's in labor
so than thank you uh representative
onor my name is Paul Burch I um reside
in West Milan if you don't know where it
is it's on the other side of Keane on
the banks of the Connecticut River and
represent three river
towns this is my sixth term um for
better for worse it's also my sixth term
on
Judiciary um I'm at the time of my
retirement I was a senior public
defender in Vermont uh which gave me the
dubious honor of being told no by more
judges than any lawyer in the history of
the state of Vermont um and I'm pleased
to be back after a 2-year uh separation
my my transplanted kidney is doing fine
and uh my interests on this committee
are very
broad thank you representative Alexander
thank you Mr chair um my name is
representative Joe Alexander I represent
the town of gtown this is my fourth term
on this committee um reminded Paul it
was my fourth consecutive term on this
committee but I like to um REM I like to
uh be the non- lawyer in the committee
um kind of add a different perspective
there um I my passions are uh housing
policy landlord tenant policy so you're
welcome for taking that out of this
committee into another committee but um
we'll still be passionate about right to
no law among other things so I'm happy
to be
back thank you uh representative
tur uh also a non- lawyer on this
committee um I'm from Brentwood New
Hampshire over near ex um and this is my
second term in the house second term on
this committee um and uh a Democrat but
I always say I I I come from a policy
background my my my work for 30 plus
years has been in um Access to Health
Care um at the state level at the
federal level the community level um you
know and I like to approach things from
from the perspective of you know what
the goals that we're trying to achieve
are um not necessarily falling into any
particular although obviously uh often
on on on my side in some issues uh what
brings me here um I I My First Choice
when I got elected was Health and Human
Services because I figured that's where
I belonged um and I was glad that I did
not get that um not because I don't like
what they do but because I do like what
this committee does um I'll I'll I'll
raft on the back of mar uh
representative Smith's uh comments you
know it it does sort of touch on sort of
the bigger picture questions around what
it means to be a citizen of New
Hampshire um what it means to have
personal freedom what it means to have
um autonomy over our life and I'm also a
a co-sponsor on the on the um death With
Dignity or whatever we're calling it
bill um so yeah very very very happy to
be here I will say you know from the
healthcare access perspective and my
wife's an obstetrician you know abortion
was probably the leading thing that Drew
me to this committee but I've been uh
very very very much uh engaged in all of
the things and very glad that
representative um Alexander has taken
the um landlord tenant bills
away thank you uh representative
Rambo yes good morning I'm Katherine
Romo I am a representative from Bedford
I think this is my second and a half
term technically I was elected in a
special election in 2021 um I previously
served red on Transportation uh for the
last few years I had been a town
counselor in Bedford um and so thought
at that time my uh experience with roads
and local speed limits and those sorts
of questions uh might be helpful in that
committee um but I am an attorney and
felt this would be a good opportunity
This this term to to bring some of my
professional experience hopefully to
bear um and I'm looking forward to to
joining the committee um I do not have
any bills in front of this committee I
do not believe this year but um last
year I was the Prime sponsor serve for a
bill that uh eliminate patient costs for
followup breast cancer screen breast
Imaging and screening uh for breast
cancer screening so it's really proud of
that work and I I know it was successful
in part because of collegial committee
efforts and um and so I'm glad to hear
that that is that is the approach here
as well thank you thank you
representative McFarland thank you Mr
chairman um Donald McFarland freshman
representative from Orange uh I have uh
four Decades of experience in
engineering science science technology
and risk management and uh to your
question I was asked by leadership if I
would consider serving on Judiciary and
and delighted to do so uh to the best of
my knowledge I'm still pending committee
assignment on a few of my bills I got
six bills and one resolution I'm Prime
sponsoring uh I don't think I have
anything before this committee um but I
am very interested in upholding the rule
of law uh and the importance of that on
our society I have a personal interest
in technology privacy and anti trust
policy uh and other actions that are
intended to promote uh individual and
societal Liberties and a strong
constituent interest in landlords rights
Right to Work abortion and other matters
that may come before this
committee right thank you well again
welcome everyone so you know what I'd
like to do I'm gonna uh pass this and U
representative Smith would you would you
mind passing that down um i' just like
to uh Bas yeah in other words this what
i' what I'd ask you to do is I I put
down
I prepared a list of all the members
with the phone numbers and email
addresses that I got off the judicial
branch website what I'd ask you to do
please is look at it and make sure it's
correct and more importantly if there's
another phone number or another email
address and you'll see that for some of
you there is no phone number listed
because I didn't have it on the we from
the website but if there's another phone
number or another email address that is
more convenient for you please please
put that
in um Mr chair I didn't see I passed it
down with um my colleagues help but I do
want to note that I believe it is the
21st or the 22nd that all of our
legislative email addresses are going to
change so I would not
um put this in stone until after that
that's good that's a good point and and
just to add to that I actually think if
somebody emails the old email address it
will go it will go to the new inbox so
it's not like the end of the world if
somebody emails your legislative email
address right yeah yeah you know what
the the just so you know the the thing
I'm most important most interested in I
mean email addresses are important but
the thing I'm most interested in is for
some of you there was no phone number
listed and so I'd like that and and
secondly is you know if the on the
website it lists your home phone number
but your cell phone is the one that's
easiest to get in touch with you please
put that down so I can get in touch with
you um we've we've just been joined by
our our new clerk representative pel
representative P we have all kind of
gone around the room just telling people
uh who we are and why we're interested
in you know in this particular committee
so well if you wouldn't mind we'd love
to hear from
you thank you uh representative Katie
peternell I um from wolfboro represent
wolfboro and hoften Boro and um I was on
the education committee last year and
that
was basically sensory overload so I am
very happy to be on Judiciary even
though we deal with a lot of heavy
topics um but uh yeah I'm I'm very
interested in being on this committee
and uh thank
you thank you um so as as I said while
this while the sheet is going around um
uh you you'll fill in your your phone
numbers and email addresses um everyone
should have gotten and I see everyone is
in the proper place the seating chart
you'll you'll notice that um I basically
triy to as we did last year to break it
up you know Republican Democrat
Republican Democrat except for the kind
of leadership up here um uh and the idea
is to you know to Foster communication
between between people who may not
necessarily agree on things uh hopefully
that that will work out um in terms of
and I know some a number of you have
raised issues with me so I guess what I
want to say is um this um we right now
the last I checked early this morning we
had 34 bills that were assigned to this
committee I'm sure that's not the end of
it we're going to I suspect we're going
to get uh uh you know last year I think
we had 43 or 44 so I you know I suspect
we're going to get something at least
around there um for uh for this year um
our you should know everyone should know
that we share this room with two other
committees on Tuesday's Child and Family
uh the child and family committee uses
this room and on Friday the state
federal relations and Veterans Affairs
uses this room
um if past experience is you know proves
to be the same this time um child and
family will be busy very busy as are we
state federal relations may be less busy
so it may be that
after uh you
know late February something like that
um uh Fridays will that this room will
be available on Fridays because at least
at least a number of times will be
available on Fridays because state
federal will will have finished um their
work but at any rate so what I wanted to
EMP empz is our typical day for meeting
will be
Wednesdays um uh but we may also have
some times particularly as we get closer
to a crossover or if we have early bills
uh that we need to deal with we may also
have to meet on Monday so there may be
sometimes when we will be meeting both
on Monday and on uh Wednesday the thing
I should emphasize for the particularly
for the new people is this
when we have hearings scheduled there is
no requirement of a quorum for hearings
so if you can't you know obviously I
encourage all of you to come I'm not
suggesting you shouldn't come it's it's
important that I think that you do come
but if for some reason you can't come
it's not going to be absolutely the end
of the world we don't have to get a
substitute for you um or anything like
that when we have executive sessions
however then we do need a quorum and it
really is important important that
everyone be here and if you're not able
to be here on a day when we're going to
have an executive session um then it's
important that if you're a republican
you let me know or if you're a Democrat
you let representative Smith know so
that we can get a substitute for you
because um particularly if a bill you
know if there are controversial bills
that are likely to to generate a
Partyline vote um it's important that
both parties have all their members here
and so we want to make sure that that um
happens Mr chair yes um in light of the
rule change that we agreed to last
Wednesday um concerning um a notice each
day each hearing day about the
possibility of executive sessions do you
have a particular policy that you're
planning to try to follow I do yes so as
you know that the um the policy had that
we've adopted last week has gone back to
to the what has been referred to as the
traditional policy which is that we if
we put if we publish a notice with the
with uh the notice of hearings that says
we can exec on any bill that has had a
hearing at any time during the course of
the day that that that you know that
we're holding hearings um then we can
then we can do that without some further
notice um what what I my what I plan to
do is this
I I I plan to take advantage of that if
it appears that we have that one of two
conditions is satisfied either everybody
is
here um or it appears that even if
everybody isn't here we J there's an
overwhelming consensus that of what we
should do and I can tell I may in fact I
may even ask for you know a straw vote
but I will I will tell you now so
because I'm not I'm not going to play
games I am not going to call for an
executive session on something that's
controversial where somebody's missing
I'm just not that I'm not going to play
that game um so if everybody's here then
I may call an executive session on
something even I suppose even if it is
controversial but U more likely what I'm
where we we're going to have an
executive session is on things that um
are you know are non-controversial and
in that case even if somebody's missing
if it you know if if uh 1777 out of 19
people are or I'm sorry 17 out of 18
people seem to think it's okay and one
person's missing or you know 16 out of
18 and one person's missing I we
probably will go ahead and and um exec
the bill and I use as an example I'm I'm
sure that you the new folks don't don't
um will not understand this but there's
a bill that we're going to be hand
hearing this afternoon representative
tur's bill on uh assistant managers in
limited liabil ility companies that we
had a significant discussion on last
year we passed it and the Senate uh the
Senate didn't didn't do its job I would
say uh or at least the other body didn't
do it didn't didn't uh for whatever
reason didn't pass it if if I had given
the notice in for for today this
afternoon's hearings which I didn't so
we can't do that but if I had given it
that would be an example of a bill where
it might make a lot of sense to
executive because I suspect you know we
uh we passed it overwhelmingly last time
I'm sure we would feel the same way um
this time um the last thing I want to
raise here is um the issue of starting
times uh there's been some uh some
issues regarding
that I seem to remember and and I'm
going to ask you to you know to to
respond to this my recollection from
last year is that we had done it
at various times both ways we had
started sometimes at 9 we started
sometimes at 10 and I I recall that we
had a discussion about it my
recollection was that most people
thought it was better to start at 10:
but I raise that again now I mean we we
could start at 9: we could start at 9:30
we could start at
10: sometimes it you know I'm going to
reserve the right to make that decision
whe When I have to sometimes it I think
it will be that we may we have we maybe
have so much to do that we just have to
start at 9: whether we you know would
prefer that or not but generally I would
like to do what most people want so can
I can I ask just ask how many people
o'clock okay how many people would
rather start at 10
o'clock well hang on
all right um and how about
9:30 I could kind of live with 9:30 0
so yeah no no I could I I just did so I
think if I can you what um so I'm just
want can the people who have trouble
with nine can you just tell me what the
what the issue I know representative
Burch lives far away and that's yeah
it's it's difficult to do
and just try to respect those who have
three hours of driving each
day is there any you know is there
anyone on the other side of it that has
you know there's a particular reason to
start early because you need to go
somewhere later on representative Perez
thank you I have two issues now the
reason why I had asked for 9:30 when I
sent out something was try to make a
compromise I have an issue with going
late in the day I have commitments that
I have to work around late in the day
but that's not the biggest thing the
biggest thing we're winter time we may
say that a hearing starts at 3:30 but if
we're way behind that may not start till
4:15 we may not be out of here until
whenever as much as we would like to be
I don't want to drive home after
dark well what I yes I'm sorry
representative McFarland thank you Mr
chairman um I I just add to that I would
Echo what uh representative Paris said
but I think um given what you were
saying about our heavy workload this
year here uh my interest would be in how
we can get the most work done in the
days that we are here uh and uh uh you
know while uh I understand uh Mr burch's
concern I you know I too have a
three-hour round trip um I I think that
if we can maximize the the use of the
daytime it would be to our advantage and
and from a personal standpoint um I have
uh a lot more meetings in the evening
than I do in the early mornings so those
are the reasons represented Alexander
yeah I I I in the spirit of compromise
I'm okay with whatever time I think what
you've done in the past is executive
sessions you've had a 10 public hearing
start at nine kind of thing um I think
that worked out decently um I bartend
for a living so you might see me jet out
early afternoons for public during
public hearing days um so that's also
part of
my reasoning okay all right uh yes
representative trip and then
representative work uh you would mention
that there's a possibility that we would
have uh uh two committee hear committee
meetings a week you know it seems that
uh if we were to do that uh we could
eliminate you know the contention over
starting early or late you know because
we would be able to get whatever we need
done you know done at uh in a a 10 to
three uh time
segment hi we got we have our chief
justice as arriv
we're I think we will continue this
discussion but um I'm G to ask the Chief
Justice and Miss krian if You' introduce
yourselves and uh we'd love to hear a
little bit about uh the Judiciary since
Committee good morning Mr chairman uh
and members of the committee thank you
very much for the opportunity we have
some slides that are they'll be passed
around for the record Gordon McDonald
I'm chief justice and with me is Aaron
krian who's the general counsel for the
judicial branch I I want to say at the
outset this is I know there are many
many returning members of this committee
and some with deep experience in the
judicial branch I don't mean to insult
anyone with these slides uh but I do
think it's helpful just to give a
baseline of information about the
okay uh slide three is just an overview
of what I'd like to cover today one give
uh the committee an overview of our
structure and two to discuss some of the
challenges and opportunities we face so
on slide four you see on the left hand
side a visual depiction of the structure
basic structure of the judish Branch we
are comprised of two trial courts
circuit court and Superior Court and one
appell Court the sup Supreme Court and
all three courts are supported by the
administrative office of the
courts and I'm going to go through Court
by court and function by function and
give you a brief overview so let's start
with the circuit court on the next slide
page five the Circuit Court was created
in 2011 by this legislature it combined
the then existing District Court probate
court and Family Division into one court
so it's a court of Highly specialized
subject matter jurisdiction virtually
all of it uh statutory just a sliver of
common law jurisdiction on the next
slide you will see that we have 10
circuits one for each County and uh 34
circuit Coral occasions around the state
that's slide
six slide seven is our judicial
headcount we are now
fully um staffed in terms of judicial
officers at 49 circuit judges 49 circuit
judges and their work is supplemented by
one those are full-time judges one
part-time judge two perdum judges and
then judicial referees and Senior judges
who uh are able who discharge judicial
functions subject to review an approval
Judge on the next slide slide eight you
will see um the filings in the Circuit
Court by case type so these numbers are
from 2023 calendar year
2023 and you will see that uh over
100,000 cases flowed through the circuit
court that year the largest single case
type is
Criminal uh and the circuit court has
driv jurisdiction over
misdemeanors uh these numbers are
subject to change in 2024 because of the
so-called unwind of felonies first um
and felonies first felonies are now back
into uh Circuit Court as an initial
matter for probable cause
determinations back to where we were uh
prior to 2016 when felonies first uh
began next slide is an overview of the
superior Court Superior Court is our
court of General jurisdiction in New
Hampshire uh it is the court where
juries jury trials are
conducted uh all felony crimes are are
heard in Superior Court and it has civil
$25,000 on the next slide you will see
an overview of our filings in Superior
Court uh these again these numbers are
from
2023 um and the largest single component
of that in 2023 is our criminal
cases both courts circuit and Superior
do handle requests for warrants search
warrants and arrest warrants and you can
see that's U about 8,600 in Superior
Court uh and circuit
handles uh those requests as well
incoming requests from law enforcement
around the state
the next slide slide 11 uh depicts our
Superior Court
locations we have 11 Superior Courts one
in each County two in Hillsboro one in
Manchester on the next slide is our head
count in terms of judges for Superior
Court we are authorized by Statute to
have 22 associate justices and one chief
justice and all of those uh positions
are currently filled their work is also
supplemented by uh senior active judges
and judicial
referees on the next slide uh give the
committee an overview of a new
development as of this year uh House
Bill 318 authorized the creation of a
new position within the judicial branch
uh called
magistrates um in December we uh swore
in
three magistrate judges the the
legislation authorizes three and then
permits me to come back and ask for two
more based on our
experience uh and you can see the
subject matter jurisdiction of the our
magistrates laid out on this slide and
that was uh pursuant to the legislation
in an order of the Supreme
Court uh they spent a month being
trained and went live on January 1st and
among other things they are covering um
where appropriate where the statute uh
requires uh bail hearings over weekends
so they are switching off weekend by
weekend and conducting bail hearings on
1 uh next slide is the Supreme Court an
overview Supreme Court is comprised of a
chief justice and four associate
justices in in ter in addition to our
pellet case load we have um
superintending Authority General over
the judicial branch and the legal
profession in New Hampshire and so we
supervise um and administr rules
relating to Bar Admissions and attorney
discipline among other things and then
work very very closely with the bar
association uh under state law every
member of every attorney in New
Hampshire is required to be a member of
the New Hampshire
bar on the next slide you will see uh
our workload Supreme Court's workload
these numbers are from
um 61 opinions issued in
2023 and
728 fi uh final
dispositions that final disposition
number is the real measure of our
workload at the Supreme Court and I do
have numbers from last year calendar
year
2024 and so that final disposition
number has increased
uh from 728 to
752 which is the highest level of
productivity if you will since 2015 at
the Supreme Court we issued 71 opinions
2024 um the administrative office of the
courts
about uh 50 full-time employees and many
many part-time employees
uh and again they provide support
services for all three courts including
our legal and legislative Council our
Communications function Financial it and
court security in our cir courts and on
page slide 18 you can see the list of
discharges so on beginning on slide 19 I
would just like to give the committee a
Ben benefit of at least our view of what
what some of the challenges and
opportunities facing the judicial branch
are slide 20 you can see them listed and
I'll go through each one of them
individually starting with challenges on
slide
21 uh Safety and
Security
uh it is um this is one issue that
really
really is of constant concern the Safety
and Security of everyone who walks
through our Doors members of the public
our court staff our
judges um
and in all of our locations around the
state we benefit from a tremendous
partnership with New Hampshire sheriffs
sheriffs are primarily responsible for
security in the Superior Courts and as I
said uh
theoc uh trains uh security officers and
deploys security officers in the circuit
court it's had some important
developments thanks to legislative
support our court security officers uh
are now uh can now will now be able to
go through a specialized training
program at police standards and training
Council directed to their unique
functions and that is that is a brand
new development and we're looking
forward to uh implementing that and we
appreciate the the U great collaboration
from police standards on that another
really important initiative is uh
because of the availability of arpa
funds we are engaging in a site by sight
physical assessment of security threats
and opportunities in each one of our
locations around the state and uh
that'll give us a catalog of of
opportunities to perhaps improve on how
our physical locations
um with respect to
security the next slide
um addresses the uh I think a very
significant challenge confronting the
Superior
Court um more than 1300 cases have been
generated from the uh issues involving
the Youth Development Center uh and
those are all in Superior Court uh they
are very resource
intensive 1300 cases against a case load
of 24,000 is
material and these it is even more
material given the complexity and nature
of these cases they are really consume a
lot of
resources and uh if chief justice Howard
were here he would tell you that the of
the dedication and hard work of the
Superior Court the judges involved and
the staff involved in processing these
cases indeed he he he has related to me
that there is an employee in our
electronic filing Center in Manchester
who gets to work
early 5:00
a.m. to be able to process all the
Motions pending motions in the YDC cases
around the
state it's a real challenge for us in
terms of
resources next slide addresses U another
unfortunately perennial challenge which
is access to Justice in any given day in
our Circuit Court up to 90% of litigant
in in many case types have no attorney
they're self-represented on either side
planner for defendant this is just a
challenge obviously for the litigants
involved but also it's a challenge for
the
system uh one important initiative uh
that the
legislature
um LED with and and has um enacted
legislation to to enable
paraprofessional
representation in many case types in all
of our circuit courts and that went live
last year and the preliminary data
information that we have coming back on
that it's it's hopeful there are lots of
opportunities to expand it uh but it is
a way to get a legally trained person
standing next to someone you on a really
important day in their lives in court
before a
judge um one issue that uh is
unfortunately persisting is with respect
to our Indigent defense
system um the engineed defense is
principally handled through the New
Hampshire public
defender uh they have experienced a
market increase in retention levels 262
per since 2010 of attorneys who are
leaving the office the retention rate
has decreased by that amount um and
that's combined with a case load that is
sort of
unrelenting and cases that are becoming
more resource intensive in part because
of the explosion of video evidence and
the amount of resources that consumes
for attorneys uh both in prosecution and
in defense uh the legislative budget
assistant conducted an audit one of its
regular audits of the judicial Council
last year in in
October uh released its report it's well
worth reading about the injured defense
system and it noted um that in March of
um 20 to 40 incarcerated defendants were
awaiting appointment of council
incarcerated defendants who are entitled
under both of our constitutions to Legal
represent ation the number for
non-incarcerated was 100 to
125 it is an issue not only of
constitutional Dimension and very
important to the defendants involved but
it also has impact on our entire Justice
System an attorney has no lawyer the
case cannot proceed and that effects
there are Ripple effects throughout the
system in both of our
courts next slide uh briefly addresses
our treatment courts
it's very important opportunity ongoing
opportunity uh with great help from the
legislature to uh
get treatment and services to those who
are flowing through our system so that
we don't see them again is basically the
idea our adult truck drug courts uh in
10 of our Superior location Court
locations with mental health courts in
both Superior and uh Circuit Court Court
uh the legislature authorized the
creation of a veterans court last year
which we were getting up and running
there was a really interesting pilot
program up in Sullivan uh family
treatment court for those families who
are involved in our abuse in a collect
system to get the services that they
need so that they um so that they can be
more successful and if they're
criminally involved can be more
successful court involved in um in not
coming back and and uh being reunited
with their families uh working with the
mayor of Manchester the circuit court is
trying to address uh in a creative and
Cooperative way the homeless issue down
there um I won't go into it but the uh
for the last couple of years systemwide
we've been engaged in a really important
initiative with respect to how the
courts can better respond to those
experiencing U mental
illness um across our state we're
conducting something called a sequential
interet mapping Workshop in each one of
our counties and it's basically an
opportunity to identify where we can get
services to those who are either court
involved
or at risk of being court involved to um
again get them the treatment they they
need the help that they need in a
clinically appropriate setting so
they're not cycling back through our
system thereby increasing Public Safety
and saving public dollars and and most
importantly getting them the help that
they
need another
um in terms of opportunities another one
um um with the support of
Grant dollars we have been able to um
get up and running a very important
diversion program in the landlord tenant
area it's a case type in the Circuit
Court 7,000 cases really high success
rate both pre-filing and post filing uh
of mediating those cases and therefore
getting uh early resolution to benefit
both parties in those cases and avoid
the time and effort of litigating uh we
are seeking to next slide um 27 we're
seeking to leverage technology to the
greatest extent possible and the
superior court is moving to a platform
to uh whereby all evidence will be
presented uh
digitally finally um we are using text
technology uh and have a couple of pilot
programs to send text reminders in both
Crim certain criminal and civil cases um
in an effort to reduce failure to appear
cost the entire system when it when
someone does not appear affects
obviously the person involved but also
the entire system and there is huge
success in meeting people where they are
and reminding them through text which uh
is how most many of us communicate about
their time in court last slide is my
contact information and that of uh
General Council kraan and we are here at
your service and look for W to working
with you over the course of the year in
this legislative session on on any
issues and Mr chairman be happy to
respond to any questions I hope that was
helpful no it was it was very helpful
thank thank you very much um let me ask
uh members of the committee questions
for the Chief Justice or for Miss gri
representative
kop thank you chairman Lynn and thank
you for taking my question Chief
McDonald uh you mentioned that there was
an access to justice issue and it was 20
to 40
um incarcerated individuals and 100 to
125 non-incarcerated is this a Statewide
issue or would you say it's more
predominant in one like certain
geographical areas than others Statewide
Statewide thank you yes representative
CH yeah thank you and thanks for taking
the question uh I was just interested in
uh your your uh highlight of the power
professional
representation um could you say a bit
more about sort of who those folks are
and how someone gets access to to them
in terms of locating them and and being
represented yeah it's a uh the
legislature very specific statute that
setting forth the education requirements
the pair of professionals and the
supervising supervision requirements of
attorneys within their office um they're
available in some but not all case types
in the circuit court but most
importantly the case types where we do
see a high volume and High High Vol
volum in high need uh based on
self-represented
litigant um the principle the report
that we just released uh to the
legislative leadership uh identifies
that most of the par professionals who
have been involved in the program have
been associated with New Hampshire legal
assistance uh there has been one I I
believe my memory is one private firm
that has used uh par Professionals in
this way so there is an enormous
opportunity to to expand the program um
and deploy it Beyond New Hampshire legal
assistance to uh to other uh
providers um and
um and I will just say you know ideally
we would want an attorney standing next
to every litigant in our court system
that is just not simply
possible but to have someone trained in
and supervised by an attorney standing
next to someone on a really important
day in their life is better than not
having someone there and that's the
logic of this program it's the logic of
the of the statute uh we all strongly
supported this legislative initiative
and we think it has great opportunity to
help close the access to Justice Gap I
hope that answered your question
representative representative Smith
thank you Mr chair could we consider
what I'm about to say as an
advertisement and not have it come out
of my questions I just want to say that
this comes from the incredibly focused
and committed work of a former chair of
this committee a former member of the
judicial branch and a former state
senator Ned Gordon who has been was
convinced for years that this would help
and this committee the the Judiciary
Committee worked very very hard for this
we had to deal with a little
um bump in the road that came having
nothing to do with the merits of the
bill from members of the other body and
in the end we were delighted that we
were able to achieve this and if nothing
else it stands as a good example of good
work that this committee can do so
that's my advertisement it doesn't count
as my
questions I hope
absolutely not other yes representative
Alexander thank you Mr chair and thank
you um chief justice for taking my
question um one thing the Judiciary
Committee also has put into statute is a
new land use Docket in the um Superior
Court spe Court um can you talk to me a
little bit about how that docket has
functioned in the sense of um if it's
sped up a lot of the cases um and how it
how it's different than the housing
appeals board that we have also put into
your branch uh so I apologize don't have
the the best data on that I think I
would be very happy to get get get it to
this committee uh we do have a dedicated
Superior
Court judge judge class who's sitting
happens to sit in
Manchester and um he
um has absorbed it took a while for him
to absorb all the volume of land use
cases uh but now that docket is fully up
and running to the extent he's not
hearing land use cases he does hear
other Superior Court cases I'm sorry
representative I just don't have the top
on the top of my head the volume of
cases or but we'd be I'd be happy to get
it to you yeah that would be great at
your convenience thank you other
questions uh yes representative
McFarland thank you Mr chairman I have a
handful of questions hopefully they
pretty simple I think um let me tackle
it one at a time first of all you assert
on slide 21 that we are subject to an
increased threat environment and I was
wondering if you could talk a bit more
about
that uh nationally we've seen uh some
really horrifying incidents involving um
courts um there was literally an
assassination of a family judge in his
driveway in Maryland in late of 2023
um
the um New Hampshire is not immune to
this it's been an increase in the
threats that we've received and the
threat and the and the um issues of
concern that we've had to deal with in
terms of our uh
security uh
Personnel um I think generally
um the environment that we are all
operating in is is challenging it really
is and and obviously we had a very
unfortunate incident at New Hampshire
hospital right here um I will note that
we have a courtroom in that facility so
it touched and it's right next door to
the conquered circuit court it's it
touched really close to home for
everyone in the judicial branch and um
and you know I I feel my number one
responsibility is to ensure do the best
we can and to make sure that we are
performing our constitutional duties in
in a place that is as safe as possible
thank you sir um you you talk about it
as as part of the function is that it
Department um separate or is it part of
Dennis gul's organization and um in the
context of that you you also talk about
movements towards more digital evidence
digital case management can you help us
understand the extent of your uh
Reliance and backup on paper uh or the
you know conversely the extent to which
were you to be subject to uh let's say a
ransomware attack that that removed
those systems from being available what
what impact would that have on the case
load to answer your first question is
separate uh Our IT department is
separate although we work closely with
Department of Information Technology
there is there is some crossover
including some of our external facing
resources website and so on um we
we uh for many many years as the chair
knows we have been working on uh
deploying to an to an all electronic
platform in terms of case management and
filings Superior Court is all
electronic some but not all case types
in Circuit Court are electronic and we
hope to get to a place where we can be
fully deployed in electronics circuit
court has certain challenges there um we
do we are very aware of the external
threats um coming in um in terms of
accessing our system again I don't have
the data right off the top of my head uh
but it is it's it is of concern to our
uh it team and it's something that's
very very much on our radar screen uh I
will say that the um the benefits of
investing in in electronic case
management were born out during the
pandemic uh when we were able to Pivot
to a quasi virtual environment pretty
quickly uh and it was the investment in
electronic case management coupled with
um our a call center we have a central
call center to handle all trial court
inquiries and it was those two
Investments and uh and initiatives both
of which had the support of the
legislature that really enabled us to
efficiently handle cases in a in a
different
environment thank you uh final question
uh did you you mentioned the
non-competitive fee structure with
regard to the the public defender office
and Eng dependence um can you give us a
sense as to quantitatively how
non-competitive it is and what your
expectation is as to what would be
needed to turn the corner on that I'm
sorry how what they the non-competitive
fee structure for the public defendant
office uh the average salary of a public
defender is I believe
$57,000 um they
can I think if you have the judicial
Council in here they will tell you a
principal concern is the um analog
organization in Massachusetts which can
pay considerably
higher um I think you will see in uh
from the judicial Council to address
this problem and get the salaries up to
where they believe it should be it's
roughly an $8 million
problem um but that and although it's
called the judicial Council it's an
executive branch agency but they they
among other things do superintend our uh
engineed vense
system 8.3 million is my memory
Smith um congratulations to you on um on
having your uh judicial your count of
Judges
where you are I don't want to say you
would want it to be but where you're
willing to accept that it is considering
it
full um some of us did put a take a
particularly Deep dive into the work of
the family court um and one of the
things we discovered that we believe
also affects the other courts is is that
the problem is not necessarily the
number of Judges but it is the absence
of support for those judges so that
judges are doing the work that could
better be done by people with other
training and other skills therefore
freeing the judges to be more judge
likee so I want to ask you a very direct
question um because you're privy to
information we're not privy to yet and
that is have you asked the Governor to
include in the governor's budget
additional staff
support for the judges in all three
levels of the judicial branch well no
actually two levels of the judicial
branch not the not the Supreme because
the Supreme Court does I think have
adequate support yeah um just for the I
agree with your observations
representative Smith I think thank you
it's the first time today oh good
okay
uh I think what the special committee
identified was in particular a lack of
Staff attorneys or the or the how staff
attorneys could benefit the Circuit
Court in dealing with its highly
specialized subject matter jurisdiction
and there are three staff attorneys now
and I think and I know you're a real
leader on this representative Smith in
terms of wanting more resource
in there the answer is
no um given the Mandate that we were
given uh in terms of the budget request
we're not able to include additional um
staff attorneys into the budget we have
identified it as a prioritized need it's
a huge priority for me personally but I
but in the interest being transparent
representative that that is where uh we
landed thank a couple of quick ones on
page 2 2 you talk about private
contractors I was a little confused
because I thought that all of those
cases had to do with
YDC no so many of them involve other
entities that delivered services to
these youth that were involved some are
just YDC other involved defendants that
may be may have provided services to YDC
or were contracted out by the state to
deliver services to the particular youth
involved and they are defendants in
those
cases thank you and one very quick
question I hope um and it has to do with
the relationship between the corps and
the bar association I believe that the
phrase that's used is that we have a
unified bar in um in New Hampshire and
that the uh as a result the bar
association is really not independent
it's part of um the the court um at how
does that differ from what we see in
other states and could you just tell me
idea uh you don't have to answer you
know any of these
questions
um
uh there are two flavors
out there among the 50 plus
jurisdictions one is to have a unified
bar and this is a statutory mandate it's
actually in statute that all all
practicing attorneys must be members of
New Hampshire Bar Association that's
called a unified bar can't remember how
many states off the top of my head
follow that system the other is to have
voluntary bar
associations where you can if you want
to be a member of a bar in in a
particular
State the unified bar uh is I think part
of its intent and purpose is to assist
the court in um in
administering the attorney population in
terms of keeping track of who they are
their addresses whether they've met
their clle requirements and so on it
serves that administrative function for
the court and I do think um you know it
delivers value in that respect attorneys
are assessed a
fee for being members of New Hampshire
bar and that fee is approved by the
Supreme Court and we do review the
budget of the bar association and make a
determination about the
fee
um I'll leave it at that it my one
little question about that is do you
think that that in any way um might put
a little bit of a crimp in the
willingness of um of a
licensed appropriately licensed attorney
in New Hampshire to um raise a
question about some of the
procedures um within the judicial branch
and since they are the people who are
most knowledgeable certainly more than
the rest of us because they're actually
in involved in the court system that
that denies us um uh means of
accountability that many of us believe
is very important
because uh because they are subject to
branch because of
natural uh unwillingness to want to um
stir the pot
yeah um
quite apart from the the nature of bar
associations and whether you're unified
or voluntary in every
state state Supreme Courts have taken
the position that the regulation of the
practice of law is a matter of within
the exclusive jurisdiction of the
judicial branch stemming from judges
organic authority to regulate what
happens in the courtroom so I'm not sure
that the to the extent you've identified
an issue I'm not sure that the form of a
bar association would make a difference
because attorneys in every state are
ultimately subject to the authority of
judges in the way that they are admitted
to the bar the way they are disciplined
their education requirements to the
extent they exist that's all in
exclusive judicial branch function well
I thank you very much for that answer
there are many of us who believe that
the judicial branch should be
responsible for its own um rules and
that wasn't too bad was it
NOK you uh representative Morton and
then uh representative for please thank
you chair and thank you chief justice
for the question uh it's two part uh
first uh we were talking about access to
Justice and you mentioned you know it's
an important day in someone's life in as
an example I graduate high High School
on one day it was the important day in
my life never had a second you know
graduation from high
school with uh people that are in the
criminal court system how many important
days are some of these people having is
it the 10th time is it and is there a
correlation the part B of that to a
certain type of representation and
so just to step back under our
constitution if you are criminally
accused for the most part you're
entitled to an attorney under the
Constitution and that goes to the issue
identified with our engine defense
system we're not there's simply not
enough attorneys in that system right
now to represent all those in need in
New Hampshire on the Civil side with
just a few exceptions
if you were involved in the court system
you're on your own in terms of hiring a
lawyer and in the Circuit Court which I
mentioned up to 90% on any given day are
self-represented they're dealing with
just real in immediate cases
involving the people we all
serve landlord tenant keeping a
house you know
shelter small claims which for many
people can be
significant uh divorce and
parenting fundamental right
parent domestic
violence you're going into the case
these courts by
yourself uh when I was a practicing
attorney I did as many pro bono cases as
I
could and um I I did them particularly
in the domestic violence area area
and when I was a practicing attorney I
even though I'd been practicing for many
had uh I got nervous walking into
court but can you imagine if you're
standing there trying to protect your
yourself your family trying to keep the
roof over your head in a completely
foreign environment
where they speak a special language and
they're specially
trained that's the issue that we're
trying to address and that's why I think
the legislature's initiative with
respect to pair of professionals is so
important you can't get a lawyer there
it's not going to happen anytime soon
but if you can get legally trained
people in there standing next to the
person on that
day it can make a real difference
representative
Horgan um yes thank you very much M Mr
chairman Mr chief justice um I was just
a little bit curious about this pilot
program um about recidivism about people
no people failing to show up at the
hearings which uh subject has been my
mind for a few months because uh this
fall um I went attended the do District
Court um I was there because there were
several defendants who'd been um who've
been arrested for trespassing in
Congressman Pap's office and they um you
know chose to exercise the right to
trial so they could like speak in their
behalf and of course they all showed up
although I think they had a volunteer
attorney didn't show up I was surprised
in that case there the judge uh was
Judge Sako Gardner of the Circuit Court
who seemed like a very very good judge
he uh had all the regular cases with
people you know who with lower profile
cases and um quite a few of them quite a
few of them
simply failed to show up so is uh so
it's a
problem it's a problem primarily here
that they don't get the word on when
they're supposed to show up or they
forget and they have the text messages
or there perhaps other things that need
to be done like possibly uh changing the
way the courts work for the people or I
hate to put any more people in in prison
we already have too many people
incarcerated but possibly increasing the
uh the penalties for when you fail fail
to appear cuz this this was a that was a
revelation to me because the only other
time in recent years been to a circuit
court was a very also high-profile case
which is serve a special circumstance
because there's a well-known State Rep
who sadly has since passed away who was
pleading guilty to simple assault and
she actually even ironically happened to
be a former County attorney so that case
they put her first in the docket and you
know so we they went and spent about
half an hour doing their thing and she
went home and we all went home and the
regular defendants you
know well process afterwards but it was
different the second time because we
were seeing all the regular defendants
and as I said I was kind of a little bit
shocked that so many of them like simply
didn't show up so so so you they're
called ftas failure appear and you've
seen the real life consequence of how
disruptive it is for the court system
but it also creates another potential
encounter for the the accused because
they failed to appear and so Tech this
technology has great promise and as I
said in the slide uh we deployed it in
cases and ftas have been reduced by 40%
so we're we we're very hopeful about
this and would we you know to address
this problem so thank you for your
question that that does sound like a
fairly lowcost and relatively simple
intervention and if it makes that big a
difference and that's definitely a good
thing so thanks representative
Manos thank you Mr chair and thank you
Mr chief justice for taking my question
I'm not familiar with felony first and
so I was wondering if you could just
expand upon
laughing
um in prior to
2016 all criminal cases including
felonies began in circuit court for a
probable cause
hearing um the legislature enacted
legislation in that provided beginning
in 20
16 um that would shift over to Superior
Court where felonies are
prosecuted um I won't it was a policy
determination in that instance by the
legislature and then uh I think it was
representative Gordon
um presented a bill to repeal that's my
memory it was representative Gordon to
repeal felonies first in 2022
and after consideration by this
committee um that was the termination of
the
legislature I I don't want to
characterize the evidence or or comment
on that policy decision but I think one
of the things and the chair probably
comment on this one of the things that
the committee heard was when cases were
first brought in Circuit Court it
created an opportunity it perceived
opportunity to resolve those cases
and that that
opportunity either didn't exist or was
put off and was not being maximized when
those first encounters shifted to
Superior Court and I think that was part
of what led the legislature to make its
decision although no I think that I
think you're absolutely right I think
that's that was that was one of the
arguments for sure yeah so um the
legislature made the decision to rewind
felonies first so we're b b back to the
status quo and
cases are beginning in circuit court now
and that is as of January 1st
2024 other other questions
sorry so red means talk thank
you I've heard a lot of great things I
was just curious just because I'm on the
school board Manchester and we're always
discussing Staffing par professionals so
I was curious if that's sort of a an
issue and I was curious what role they
played like I can imagine based on what
you said but I was just kind of curious
about that because I already had like
three ideas in my head as to how we
could always keep the you know keep our
turnover low for Paras but I'm just
curious if that's something you're
experiencing uh I'm
sorry
experiencing CU you said you're
partnering
with for perz you said who was the
organization New Hampshire legal
assistance is yeah all right I was just
kind of curious about that because I
know it's a challenge for a lot of
districts I was just curious if you're
experiencing the same thing uh to my
knowledge no but
um well thank you for training them
and we we actually don't train them but
they're trained and supervised by the
organizations either Law Firm or or in
this since New Hampshire legal
assistance which is a law firm other
other
questions yes representative M grian
please representative I've been promoted
demotion uh I know that I I know many
members of the committee um and and that
you all um you know have my contact
information for but for those that are
new I just wanted to briefly introduce
myself I'm the general counsel for the
court system and I will with his
permission leave by representative
Morton a a small stack of business cards
with my cell on the back my my um desk
phone my email uh please reach out to me
anytime that you need any information or
anything from the court system in order
to discharge your duties obviously a lot
of folks in the court system are in
adjudication during the day my intention
is to be a single point of contact for
you to get you the information that you
need um so that you're not styed by uh
anybody being unavailable uh so please
do reach out however much you need to
and you'll see me from time to time here
and and you're always welcome to request
that I be present at any hearing uh in
case there is anything that you need
system yes this is a Harris he's our
Communications manager uh
and he very kindly produced uh the high
quality color PDFs that you have there
so uh he was kind enough to come by as
well all right great any any last
question yes representative McFarland
thank you one last question um I I know
that uh you know as we've been talking
about everyone deserves their right at a
fair defense um and I I'm sure that that
is part of the consideration that
applies to associate Supreme Court
Justice Marcone at what point does the I
I I don't think we can get into anything
about any any you know anything about
any pending cases yeah I wasn't going to
ask anything about the case Mr chairman
okay my my question is simply at what
point does the absence of one of our
associat Supreme Court Justices uh start
to cause a problem I understand we have
the practice of uh appointing others on
a rotating basis um is there a point at
which we should appoint somebody on a a
protm
basis um we have established procedures
to deal with
um disqualifications or absences by
justices and we follow those it's
actually set forth
statute uh so that's the procedure that
we handle that we follow uh in terms of
the productivity the Supreme Court um as
I related we
have disposed of in 2024 752 cases that
is the most we've disposed of since
2015 so uh there are es and flows in the
membership of anybody any court and uh
you just deal with the
workload all right all right thank you
very much both of to both of you for
coming in and Miss krian I'm sure we we
will see you uh on a regular basis at uh
again thank you very much Mr Chief
like where you're from why you're
interested in the Judiciary Committee uh
your High service that kind of
thing good morning pleasure to meet
everybody that I haven't met well I
think I've met most everybody except for
a couple of you um but this is my second
term I'm from winam I didn't say at the
and I guess you know after sitting on
the committee last year there were quite
a few interesting things that kind of
came up that I
felt are really important in the
judicial system and and that kind of
just got me interested in in the
committee
so thank you and representative
Virg thank
you I'm Dan the reason why I'm sitting
in this chair is because someone
suggested it for one thing which I'm
glad that they did I like I said about
the the school board so I felt like some
of that because I've been doing it for
six terms sort of feeds into what here
as far as respect and follow the rules
and once I know them all but um so I was
asked to run for this and I
thought that's a great way to represent
my ward and my district simply because I
do both the education and the
legislative part so I think that's the
reason why I'm here thank you thank you
all right um I think i' I think we have
anybody else do we have anybody
else oh no she she she spoke you spoke y
she
introduced um are these phone numbers
just for the committee's consumption or
would they be
public um I for my per if you didn't put
your phone number on the you know on the
website then as far as I'm concerned you
didn't want your phone number to be
public so I'm not GNA you know I'm not
going to publish that to the uh to the
outside world um so you know what I want
to say I want to go back and just follow
up on the time issue um I guess based
upon what I've heard it seems like most
people would prefer to start at 10: I
guess what I would say is this okay I
will unless there is what I considered
to be sort of a really compelling reason
to start at 9: I will not start at 9: as
between 9:30 and 10: I'm I'll sort of
think about I guess uh for for what I
would say is uh you'll notice that I
have I sent out an email this morning
I've scheduled some hearings for the
29th and I did schedule those for 9:30
and that's because I knew I I knew that
one person that was particularly
concerned about because of the time was
representative Birch and he's he's not
going to be with us that week um so that
didn't seem to any reason not to start
at 9:30 that week but uh for going
forward I'll I'll sort of think about it
it'll be generally will be between
either 9:30 or 10 the other thing oh I'm
sorry no I'm sorry if we are going to be
scheduling an executive session
right would that be a 10 that
I I think I would generally try to
particularly if it was going to be just
an executive session yes I think that
would make that would make sense to do
that um because that's not that is not
something that would likely be we're not
going to be going into the late you know
five o'clock in the evening on an
executive side I hope it's not at least
I hope not um uh so that brings me this
all brings me to a very important thing
that I want to let everybody know about
and and the the speaker knows about it
uh representative man knows about it and
representative Smith knows about it but
you probably all don't know about this
and that's why I am going to be
gone from February 5th to February 24th
so that means three Wednesdays I'm going
to be gone and uh representative Manion
will be in we're going to have hearings
during that time I intend I intend just
so you understand I intend to schedule
after Consulting with representative
Manion and representative Smith I intend
to schedule hearings for all of those
three weeks um it'll be you know you'll
be here on Wednesday these for full days
on those but I will not be here and
that's because I have a longstanding uh
I'm a longstanding plans to go on a trip
to Thailand and Vietnam and Cambodia and
so that's where I will be uh for for
those for those three weeks um and as I
said you know I again I understand I
particular M representative McFarland I
understand that you know and and others
I understand you you have you have other
lives and I you know completely
understand that sometime you have to you
have to either for business reasons or
other other reasons you may not be able
to be here I completely understand that
um but I will would we figure there
would not be exact sessions one yeah you
know what what I suggested is um and I'm
I'm going to talk further to
representative Manion and and
representative Smith about this but my
inclination is on anything that you know
appears that there's going to be a
debate so to speak that that we wait
until so I'm back to have the executive
session on that if there are some things
that you again I go back to
representative tur's Bill if you know if
that came up on that on the time and
everybody said you know wait a minute
this is a no-brainer Let's either do it
or let's not do it fine you should do
that I have complete confidence in
representative Manion and representative
Smith that uh to use your uh your good
judgment on those kind of things um all
right so that would mean there um Mr
chairman that we would not have
executive sessions on um complex bills
until the first week in March till the F
until the first week because because we
will have we will not have that during
the um that vacation the vacation yes
because I in other words I will be back
on Monday I think it's Monday February
24th but that's the week that we will
not the house will not be U sitting so
we will be the next time we will you
know get together will be the will be
the the following week now as I say as
I'm thinking about this and I'm trying
to put together the schedule um it may
be that sometime in early March
particularly if there are some early
bills that we you know that we need to
uh that we need to exec or whatever that
we may have to um uh have an executive
session on a Monday in in you know
either that first week or second week
but I'll I'll try to avoid that if at
all possible because I don't you know if
we can if we going to particularly
representative Alexander who's got
another another chairmanship uh on the
housing committee which is going to be
pretty busy I will I will try to avoid
having two days if it's all possible but
I can't guarantee it um all right uh
let's see let me go what else do I that
I want to talk about here
um I I went over the Executive session
issue um oh so you know that the this is
you you may have
already uh particularly on on on
representative Smith's side of the aisle
she may have already discussed this with
you I have not discussed it with my uh
folks on my side of but but just as a
general
thing I think it will usually be the
practice that before there is an
executive session each myself for the
Republicans representative Smith for uh
for uh the Democrats or it my absence uh
representative Manion for the
Republicans will have a caucus usually I
did it last year and I would probably do
it again this year would do it uh by
Zoom uh you know
the the night before a couple of days
before whatever where we'll kind of go
over uh the bills that we're going to be
executing and get some sense of what um
people's position are are on the bills
and U and the same would be true on the
uh on the on Dem itic side and I you
know
I let me just I let me say this because
I um this is this is from my
perspective from my perspective on the
Republican
side if if some Bill is a priority of
the leadership of the house I'm going to
tell you that that's true and that
that's you know this is what the um what
the leadership would like to have happen
I don't try to Strongarm anybody you do
what you want to do um I will tell you
that you know if something is important
to the leadership that that's that's a
significant thing to consider personally
there are you know there are there are
things where I might personally think H
I don't know about this but it's
important to leadership and and it and
I'm not so opposed to it that I'm that
I'm gonna you know if leadership wants
it I'm going to go along with it because
that's you know that I think that that's
kind of part of what comes with with
being a committee chair on the other
hand there are some things where I just
feel so strongly that you know I just
can't do it and I expect that all of you
have that same view also I don't know
what the situation is on the Democratic
side I leave that to representative
Smith and she doesn't you guys don't
have to tell me and I shouldn't know
that Mr chair to
[Laughter]
yeah I would just say this would be a
great conversation to have in a
republican caucus I'm sure it would I'm
sure it would um all right yes um if I
if of the rumors we've been hearing are
true you'll probably miss two session
days so I suppose as a courtesy to you
if there's anything we think might come
down to one vote one way or the other
you'd rather have us uh put that off and
get it out of the way wait till after
you come back or not session well I you
know I don't have I don't have
uh I'm not sure what the speaker intends
to do on session he knows that I'm not
going to be here and I he'll you know
he'll make his decision uh yes
you we have a couple of bills coming to
us that are going to require a
tremendous amount of time like last year
in
hearings I would
hope that those bills when people come
to speak speak are able to speak and
interruption I had a lot of complaints
from people last year when we stopped
the hearing and told people to come back
hours later and I would hope that we
learned from
our mistakes in that and that that does
not happen again
here I well I guess all I could say all
I can say is this we I mean just you've
probably seen I assume one of the things
you're talking about is the end of life
Bill absolutely yeah so that has been
scheduled for January 29th at 1 p.m. uh
we'll start at 1M and we'll you know
we'll go that's the last bill of the day
that is the last bill of the day that's
what I'm I didn't look to see what had
been scheduled um okay and I you know I
suspect um
probably um sometime after that uh we're
going to have there I think I think we
have at least one maybe actually two
maybe more uh because we haven't gotten
all the bills yet abortion bills I
suspect those are going to take up uh
you know those are going to take up some
time too and in fact for next week we
have some right to no bills I you know I
suspect some of those may may take some
time and uh I'm just asking for an inter
not an interruption in people who come
to vote come to to a hearing that
they're not told to come back later
that's all well I you know I mean I I
can't guarantee that but we'll do the
best we can sure okay thank you all
right other um let me me see what else I
wanted to
uh
um
um all right the last thing I want to
and then I want to answer any questions
or have any discussion you might want to
have but the last thing I want to um
talk about is as several people
mentioned um I'm very proud of the fact
that um last year our committee we had
very strong disagreements as you as
people who are here uh will remember
remember we had any number of bills that
came that came out of the committee with
no recommendation uh because we were
split 10 we had 20 people on the
committee at that time it was 10 to 10
um and um so there's no question that
the members of the committee then and
I'm sure the members of the committee
now have very uh different ideas on
things and I that's fine that's what
democracy is all about but I think it's
really important that both in dealing
with the public that is you know
Witnesses or people that are here in the
room and just as important with each
other that we treat each other with
dignity and respect um it's you know I
regard representative Smith as my friend
and as a member of the loyal opposition
and I hope she regards me the same way
and that's the way I regard all of you
so uh and I hope you will uh all have
that same mindset there are no enemies
here they're just people who have
different views um and it's really
important I think for the public that
they understand that this you know we
this is the
legislature um it's not some bar room uh
and we need to be a acting like it's a
place where we treat each other with
dignity and respect and that's about all
I have to say um representative Perez
yeah I'm sorry I have one more question
when you're away and we're doing
hearings are you also going to put at
the bottom of them that an executive
session might be available if we have
something that's a very benign bill that
we all are in GLE we can do that right
now as I said yes I am I think you
should and by the way you know I'm I'm
planning to be I I obviously I can't say
for sure what the internet availability
is going to be particularly in Cambodia
or Vietnam but Thailand Maybe a little
different but I'm going to try to keep
up with what's going on and be available
if representative Manion wants to talk
to me or you know email me or whatever
how successful that will be I don't know
but I'm going to try um all right are
there is there are there things we
haven't discussed that anybody wants to
talk about just yes represent me and we
haven't talked about this so I'm not
sure how you run it here but I know in
criminal justice when we're asking
questions uh of people here to testify
that we ask one question not I have two
or three or four of them it just gives
other people on the uh on the committee
time to speak yeah no no no that that
that's true I didn't that that is the
process we should follow if you if you
have a question ask the question if you
have a followup you can ask to have a
followup um and generally it's going to
be fine but if there are a whole bunch
of people that all have questions I
might say wait a minute hang off hang on
on your followup let's let somebody else
ask a question first um but gen yeah
um oh yes represent B I actually have a
comment I wanted to apologize for being
late but I sat there in the governor's
office because it said 208 on it so I
don't even know what lb stands for to be
quite honest with you so I apologize no
no no problem no you know the other
thing to say the other thing I that
really raises a good question you know I
had I had a lot of experience in
judicial procedures based on my career
in the I had very little experience in
legislative procedures when I got here
and in fact I still don't don't by any
means consider myself to be an expert on
on legislative procedure so you're going
to find a number of times when I'm when
I'm looking to representative Smith and
saying okay what what's the rule here
what am I supposed to because she's been
here for 25 years or more than that um
and uh don't rub it in and so um I guess
what I'm my point here is the there are
as far as I'm concerned there are no
dumb questions if you have a question
about how something should operate don't
feel embarrassed to ask it uh we you
know it's important that you feel
comfortable and you know that everybody
kind of knows what knows what uh what
the score sheet is so to speak other
than that um anything else before we uh
recess for lunch and then we'll be back
uh to start our
hearings anything else all right seeing
nothing thank you um we'll see you in a
hour
e
um all right I'm going to uh call the uh
Judiciary Committee back to order and uh
commence the hearing on uh HB 88 uh FN
uh relative to establishing community
property trusts and I will recognize uh
the prime sponsor representative Dan
McGuire thank you Mr chairman and
members of the committee for the record
my name is Dan Maguire I represent the
town of
epom so
um this B bill is motivated by a
situation that could occur to a New
Hampshire widow or
widower um where they would be at a
disadvantage regarding federal tax
compared to someone in the exact same
situation who lives in California or
some other state right so this is a a
solution or a possible solution um for
such a person uh it's a tool that lets
them fix that uh while the person's
still married right so they would have
to act while they're married in order
for this to happen so to give you the
background I'm going to have to explain
some things about federal income tax uh
number one is there's a there's a part
of the income tax is a capital gains tax
so a capital gains tax is if you own
something typically real estate could be
stocks could be bonds could be art could
be anything and and over the lifetime
that you own it the value of that thing
goes up in in value and you so you buy
it for one price you sell it for another
price you owe a tax uh the capital gains
tax on the difference and the the amount
of the tax varies depending on the time
you owned it and uh the amount of your
your other taxes things like that but
that's what a capital gains tax is it's
a tax on the difference in value when
something goes up you know when it goes
down you have a negative um capital gain
which you can write off other capital
gains but but in general when something
goes up you you will in general owe a
tax on that capital gain now what if you
receive property by inheritance right
your your uncle dies you know your uncle
owns 100 shares of Microsoft he bought
it for
$100 it's now worth
$1,000 um and uh he dies and leaves it
to you okay um and you sell it do you
have a $900 capital gain the answer is
no so when you receive property from an
inheritance at you your basis your your
kind of starting point for that property
is the value on the day you got it so it
was worth $1,000 when you got it you
sell it for $1,000 there's no no gain no
tax okay um if there is any tax owed in
this situation it would be on your
uncle's estate it wouldn't be part of
you okay in but in general there isn't a
tax okay so those are the the two Basics
so let me give you an example of how a a
widow or widower can get hurt so this is
on this paper I handed out here suppose
Mr Mrs same example Mr Mrs Jones buy a
$100 worth of stock and they put it in
their joint brokerage account so they
have an account with Fidelity or Schwab
or one of those things they buy a stock
so over time the value of this stock
becomes a th000 okay um then Mr Jones
dies and Mrs Jones inherits the stock
and then Mrs Jones sells the stock for
$1,000 okay now if the Joneses happen to
live in California or another community
property State then um they get what's
called a step up in basis for all
Inherited property including this kind
of property community property so so Mrs
Jones would then own the stock with a
value with a basis of $1,000 a starting
point of $1,000 she sells it for $1,000
no no gain no tax okay but if Mrs Jon if
the Joneses live in New Hampshire then
the way the IRS treats this is that Mrs
Jones owned half of it from the start Mr
Jones owned half of it from the start so
the so the half that Mrs Jones gets from
Mr Jones that has a step up in basis
right so it as far as Mrs Jones is
concerned it's worth five she got it
when it was worth $500 it's still worth
$500 no tax on that part but when she
sells her own part that she got for
$50 and now sells it for $500 there's a
$450 capital gain and she would out tax
on that so so and the only difference in
my example is she you know living in New
Hampshire versus living in in California
or one of these other community property
States so um so what this bill does is
allow someone a married couple to create
a trust with this community property
feature and they could put this stock or
any other property into the trust one of
them dies the other inherits and the
entire value of the trust gets the Step
Up in basis so they wouldn't owe a
federal capital gains
tax okay it's totally optional it's a
new kind of trust it exists in some
other states so now why do we have this
weird you know federal tax situation it
has to do it's I can get into it with
questions if you want but it it has to
do with the history of how laws were
created in the various States and some
states have this kind of feature for all
married coup's property all right and
those states are called community
property States and there's a list of
them here
Arizona California Idaho Louisiana
Nevada New Mexico Texas Washington and
Wisconsin now Wisconsin is the
interesting one of that group because
the others all started with community
property from day one but Wisconson in
the 70s switched from being like New
Hampshire to being like these other
states and they did it deliberately for
this exact reason for this this tax
reason um and when I was originally in
the legislature like 12 years ago I
proposed that we do the same thing like
Wisconsin but um the legislature didn't
want to basically because it was too big
a change right it would Chang everything
right it changes all of these kind of
property matters so we didn't do it but
in the meantime since then um this
alternative method of getting this
feature but only getting it optionally
and if you want it came came about and
since and these other five states have
adopted community property trusts as a
as a feature of their states and those
are the states of Alaska Florida
Kentucky South Dakota and Tennessee so
this bill is modeled on what we have for
Tennessee uh I think they were one of
the first that to do this and um it
would just add us to that particular
list as having this kind of a trust be
an option for people to have now what I
find interesting about this list is
except for Kentucky these are all other
states that don't have um their own
state income tax so I think it's people
who are more sensitive to their citizens
paying federal income tax right I mean
they're it's on their minds I guess and
it also um because they themselves don't
have capital gains taxes then this
wouldn't affect them themselves it's
only about federal tax okay um now one
thing you might notice in the bill it
has a fiscal note which says that uh the
amount the cost of the bill is
indeterminate
because it might uh preclude uh certain
uh real estate transfer tax payments now
I actually think that when you for
estate planning purposes create a trust
and put put in property into that trust
then that isn't a a real estate transfer
tax event but it's something I'm I'm not
authoritative on that so so I tend to
think you know you're effectively taking
property you own and giving it to
yourself under a different name so there
shouldn't be a real estate transfer tax
uh event there you know it's only when
you sell a property to somebody else
then there that's a real estate transfer
tax so I think this is really no no cost
but um that's something I could look up
and and find out more about if you
thought it was significant I tend to
think if we didn't have the provision in
there to to say this is not a real
estate transfer tax event then probably
very few people would Avail themselves
of this feature I mean it's a nice to
have it's not
a end of the world kind of thing okay so
that's the fiscal note and then um I
have an amendment for you so it's brand
new bill but but in the meantime after
we created the bill um I was contacted
by the bankers and Association and they
pointed out that it it it there's a
there's a flaw in the bill in that
suppose one uh the husband or wife owns
a piece of property that has a mortgage
on
it um and then they decide to make this
property community property by putting
it in the trust right technically the
mortgage is owned by that one person it
is owed by that one person right it's
let's say the husband bought a a house
got a mortgage on it then they got
married then they put it into such a
trust um now the house would be owned
50/50 by these two married people right
so therefore the husband owes the money
but both of them own the property and
you got a problem because maybe the
collateral on this loan is not big
enough anymore right so so there this
amendment um takes care of that
situation so it would be both people
would still be responsible for the
mortgage or the you know the entire
value of the properties uh you know is
still on the hook sort of for that
mortgage that's that's the point of this
so I'm I'm totally on board with this
this correction I think it that was just
a case that we hadn't thought about when
we wrote this bill and I'm happy to
answer
question questions for this oh yes
representative
Birch thank you Mr chair thank you uh my
friend and
representative um I want to ask you
about the area that you said you weren't
paying much attention to and that is the
uh reduction in the state's general and
education funds that this bill would
um would do um would you have an
objection since you say the purpose of
this bill is not to uh create um a tax
shelter system would you have any
problem uh an with an amendment that
took out number one which first thing
says that an otherwise taxable transfer
transfer yeah that's something I would
have to look into I mean again
it's
um yeah I I I think I would need an
attorney to tell
me in what case that comes up because I
I have a feeling
that if you read the real estate
transfer tax stuff it it probably says
if you create a I don't know what's the
name of the trust like a like a
um
um I don't know give me an example of an
estate trust right I mean you you create
a trust for the purpose of of estate uh
planning um and you transfer property in
that trust then I'm I'm I'm assuming
that under real estate transfer tax it
says we don't you know accept for that
kind of transfer right and so this would
be the same thing so I I assume that
this line is just there because uh
there's another line somewhere else that
says I created this other kind of trust
and you know you see what I mean so so
this is intended to be like other trusts
not that it's trying to be some from the
New Hampshire point of view come some
yes
regardless of intent or desire and the
like if
this Bill and I'm talking about the
section one creating this exemption from
paying the real estate property tax can
you also do you have information glader
on finance about how
much this
provision would cost your the taxpayers
of the State of New Hampshire it's it
and
or even a range 100 million 50 million
do we have any idea from you what this
would actually cost the taxpayers so
again I would tend to think that if
doing this creates a real estate
transfer tax event people wouldn't do it
right so so in my mind there isn't any
cost but but I I can try to I'll find
out for you um number one I'll look I'll
look at the rest of this
paragraph uh I'll look at the rest of
RSA 78b colon 2 and see if there's other
exemptions in there for other kinds of
trusts right because I have a feeling if
you looked at it there would probably be
you know all these kind of estate trusts
are are in there and this would just be
yet another one so
um yeah I mean again it essentially um
right now nobody's creating this kind of
a trust right and so uh um they're not
changing the ownership of their property
and therefore there's no tax right so so
I guess I don't see
how uh creating this kind of a trust and
and somebody just they still own their
you know they owned their property
before they own it now it's just in a
different under a different technical
title I don't see how that's a taxable
event so but I'll I'll find out a little
bit more and I'll get back to you on if
if any trust type activity creates real
estate transfer
events how much money is
involved thank you representative other
other questions for this
witness representative Manos thank you
Mr chair thank you representative
McGuire for taking my questions um I
read line 12 on page
two as giving the grantour of the
trust the ability to decide on um what
the division would be at the dissolution
of the marriage and I'm wondering if I'm
[Music]
okay
so um the trust is has to be that each
person has a has a one half share in in
the community property um while they're
alive and I think what this is saying is
you can say where it
goes um among after
um dissolution death Etc but
um in general this it's intended that
that um all of the property goes to the
other spouse right I
mean this is I I have a feeling that
when it says death here um this is has
to do with if death if if both die they
could they could um uh you know that's
what that's about it's not about one
person dies because when one person dies
with this kind of a trust the other
person inherits that's the whole point
of it may I may I have a follow yeah
um but one of the reasons that this
would come into effect could be divorce
is that correct oh yeah
well yeah yeah but but
um at time of divorce then um the
property is still half and half right so
um it would be part of their divorce
settlement what what happens to the
property there's no
um there would be no benefit I think to
having this as community property in the
case of divorce right so it's it's the
only benefit to this has to do with
what happens when somebody inherits um
uh at the you know when when one becomes
a widow or widower so so under divorce I
don't think there's any difference
between this kind of trust and regular
joint
property follow yeah so in your view the
the Family Division would still have the
ability for example in a fault divorce
in New Hampshire or alimony would still
be able to take the Corpus of the trust
and say no the wife gets 60% and the
husband gets 40% is that your
understanding yeah I think you're asking
me something beyond my knowledge so I
would tend to think yes right but again
the same event if if that's what's
allowed with a current you know joint
checking account or something then I
would say yes okay thank you I I lived
just just for interest I mean I I lived
in a community property state for as an
adult for 13 years and and there was
nothing odd about our you know all of
our accounts were community property but
there was nothing strange about divorce
or
um or other characteristics of those
accounts right I mean we both could use
them and deal with you know use the
money in them and things like that it it
was just it it was a feature that made a
difference um well it had two two sort
of differences one is that uh it was the
difference and death that we talk about
here and one person inherits all that
but but also in a community property
State it's impossible to have sort of
your own if your own you get income the
marriage gets income right there's not a
you know it's not like I can have my own
checking account and my income goes to
my account my wife's income goes in her
account and they're completely separate
we can do that here you cannot do that
in a community property state but that
doesn't have anything to do with this
trust because creating this trust
doesn't change the basis of our law
right so if I may Mr chair one more yeah
thank you um I just am concerned that
the terms in in New Hampshire If This
Were to be law that in New Hampshire the
terms of the trust would
supersede or become relevant in the
divorce and the ability of the court to
divide the property um and that's that's
my concern I understand and and I guess
I'm I'm going to plead ignorance on that
one but I'll see if I can find out about
that one too right other questions for
this represent representative tur yeah
thanks Mr chair and and thanks for
taking the question um and I'll preface
not a lawyer not a tax person um in the
title it says it's establishing
community property trusts but I'm having
trouble understanding is this a new type
of trust or is this a modification to
what would otherwise be sort of an
existing type of trust in New Hampshire
like IR revocable trust Family Trust um
and is it an either or situation because
I'm not really clear like how would it
interact so yes it's an either or thing
um it's it's like those other trusts
only in the sense that they're trusts
right so a trust is kind of a box that
you put things in or or a title you give
to property right and and it has
features and it has an agreement and it
has all that stuff but but it is a new
kind of trust in the sense that only
five other states have this kind and um
you know we would be the sixth one
that's all so quick followup sure maybe
quick um so if if someone's family had a
rable trust in place and wanted to
exercise this feature they would
basically have to dissolve their
existing trust and move to a community
property trust that and could you add
all the other features of you know
irrevocable trust into into this vehicle
I'm just trying to understand how
disruptive this would be can a trust
contain another trust or well that's why
I was wondering is it separate or or is
it a modification because it seems like
if it's a completely either or it's
you're either in revocable say or in a
Community Trust then it seems like it
could cause a lot of disruption in terms
of the way people currently have things
set up to move to this thank you for the
question so um again this is probably
beyond my uh my level I think we have an
attorney coming who you can answer this
question I personally would think that
you can't put a trust inside another
trust right so so I think you have to
put property in trusts and therefore yes
you would have to take apart one and to
start another yes but again you know
even if this is not you know sort of
universally applicable for everybody's
situation there's still plenty of people
who could take advantage of this
especially if they're starting fresh
right I mean if they're doing their
estate planning starting now this would
be yet another option to do right
so the fact that some people have
existing setups that are not applicable
to this that's not a particular reason
not to do it in my opinion other
questions so and maybe I oh I'm sorry
representative B go
ahead thank you Mr chair
strange questions but I'm going to ask
them
anyway uh I guess I'm going to ask you
based on the research that you've done
from the other states can you tell me if
there's positive and negatives that came
out of that since some people have
already had it effectively I won't say
effectively but they've obviously
already been working with this system do
we know any of the highs in lows
of yeah I I think it's from what I can
tell it's it's quite simple and and it's
the advantage is the tax advantage I was
talking about and and I haven't read any
kind of anything negative I haven't read
anybody saying boy I had one of these
and it screwed me up in such and such a
way or anything like that so so no I
don't I don't see any
negatives any surveys you've
done okay but again I I would say you
know this is something that's that's
sort of new in the last 10 years right
so the number of people who have taken
advantage of it who have had deaths etc
etc is probably not
huge in my you know from what I can tell
just one followup sir
sure now I know that there's uh I've
heard of a trend even in my neighborhood
where you know a person of color could
not buy directly
through channels most other people would
they have to buy the house directly from
the owner so I'm just wondering would
this affect that at
all yeah I I doubt it yeah I mean I I
don't know about that kind of a
situation that seems illegal I'm just
wondering if it's something that could
help them versus you
know okay the the situation you're
describing I think is illegal right so
you
know um yeah
other but I was curious thank you yeah
other
questions seeing none thank you very
much representative Maguire thank you Mr
chairman yes uh next we have uh
representative I'm sorry not
representative but uh Ryan hail and Rob
sorry good afternoon chairman Lyn and
honorable members of the Judiciary
Committee uh for the record my name is
Ryan hail vice president of government
relations for the New Hampshire Bankers
Association we have 40 member banks uh
that employ roughly 6,000 people in this
great State uh we're usually not in
front of uh this committee so it's great
to be here today um with me I have Rob
deedle our general counsel from the
Gallagher calian garell Law Firm here in
Conquer New Hampshire and we just wanted
to make ourselves available uh to answer
any questions committee members May have
in regards to the amendment that uh
representative Maguire uh brought before
the committee and would like to publicly
thank representative Maguire for cons uh
considering that
Amendment and uh questions for these
Witnesses so know so can I just make so
I just want to make sure that I'm
understanding what this amendment does
is it basically says if if you establish
a community proper trust and some of the
property that you put into that trust is
subject to a mortgage the the mortgage
the the uh mortgage e the bank doesn't
get hurt doesn't lose some right it
doesn't lose sort of half the interest
in the property or whatever is that that
basically correct yes go ahead Rob uh
that is correct so the concern that came
to my mind is if you have a property
that's worth let's say a million dollars
and it has an $800,000 mortgage on it
and you transferred into one of these
trusts and that's the only asset in the
trust now under the legislation before
the amendment was introduced um the bank
the Creditor would only be able to try
and seek um its security interest up to
half of the value of that property and
there actually was a spillover issue
that the amendment addressed too well
it's not truly within our concern on the
bankers Association side we added we
suggested language that also addressed
lean holders with the thought that this
could also impair um Municipal uh real
estate property tax leans and making
sure that those also weren't going to be
impacted so I think this amendment the
way we've drafted it also encompasses
sort of all creditors and lean holders
that might be they're all held harmless
they're all they're all their interest
is going to not be diluted by going into
the trust um the other piece uh is in
section c of that area I don't have the
line number I apologize um this would be
line 11 uh we clarified that obligations
incurred by both spouses it says during
marriage was the original language um we
clarified that it's during or before
marriage contemplating that there might
be scenarios where an unmarried couple
has purchased a house together that has
a mortgage on it and they've transferred
it into the trust and then they've later
gotten married and I think the original
language had some ambiguity about what
the impact of that would be as well so
all
right um questions for this um either of
these WI
seeing none thank you thank you very
Roger I'm not sure I could gone gown I'm
please oh I'm sorry that's the next bill
ohop sorry about that so is there anyone
else here to testify on
HB
88 um you know what can I just um do we
still have the uh the two yeah you know
can I I'm sorry can I ask you the
attorney to come up just for one
question I want to make sure I'm
understand so I wonder if I could follow
up on a question that representative tur
asked I think the prior witness
if if I'm understanding correctly if
somebody has an existing trust an
existing let's say revocable trust
and this law became effective and they
didn't change to make their revocable
trust a community property revocable
trust the only thing that would happen
is they wouldn't get the benefit of this
but there would am I correct in
understanding there would be no there
would be
no for lack of a better term affirmative
harm to them they just wouldn't get the
does the micophone with a large caveat
which is I'm not a trust State's
Attorney and I didn't view the bill with
that lens however that being said um
looking at it I believe what what a
trust and estate's attorney would do is
if they wanted to have a trust treated
as a community property trust they'd
want to do something to specifically
invoke that in the trust instrument to
say that they're they're lumping it
within this RSA as created and I don't
think there's anything that I observed
in reading this that would sort of supon
automatically um transform one into a
community property trust I think it
would have to be a specific election so
they might have to perhaps do an like an
amendment to the trust saying that this
the trust that was is established as a
community property that that's my
reading subject to that caveat okay
other questions in light of my question
all right thank you very much thank you
um anyone else here who uh wishes to
testify on House Bill
88 all right seeing none I'm going to
close the hearing on House Bill
and
and I will recognize the uh Prime
sponsor
oh no
problem thank you Mr chair thanks
members of the committee um my name is
Eric tur representative tur from
Brentwood um and here to introduce House
Bill 98 um for those who were here in
the previous uh session you will
recognize this um as being effectively
identical to what was house
1082 um during during the last session
um and I'll explain a little bit about
why that is um it is a bill that I
brought um in response to a constituent
request and and uh Mr gown uh from my
town is here um and he will uh speak to
that as well um he and his um business
attorney basically put this um the idea
before me um uh made the mistake last
time around of using the word simple
when introducing the bill because it
seemed simple but we not make that
mistake again
um
uh and I'll explain it in a minute but
uh in in terms of the disposition of
last um sessions Bill uh there was there
was some discussion about how this
impacts different professions and
different um professions that use the uh
limited uh PLL l c professional limited
liability vehicle um for their for their
organization um that went to a
subcommittee um and uh resulted in an
amendment to clarify some things in the
bill um and then basically passed out of
our committee not unanimous there were
there were still a couple of of
reservations but um it went to the floor
um and passed on a Voice vote from the
house um in terms of why it's back again
it uh it then went to the other body um
and uh at the hearing um uh one of the
folks uh that had been on our
subcommittee from this committee um
basically had asked that committee to
pause their exec for a minute um while
the bar association's Ethics Committee
was going to meet in a short period of
time after that day um and basically
what that led to was there was no time
left in the session and they had
perceived that there was a problem from
the bar association I don't want to
speak for the bar association but uh no
problem was ever brought to my attention
um so it went to interim study for uh
the concern that there was something
that they had not heard um and so that
was the res that was the the termination
of the bill uh in the last session and
that's why it's back essentially in its
full form um and again if there are
issues we glad to deal with them but
hopefully um they're they're not um so
starting off on what this bill is uh
it's modification to 304 D12 which is
the area of law that that deals with um
this particular type of uh corporate
structure called the professional
limited liability Corporation or
pllc um and what a pllc is my own
interpretation of what it is it's really
a combination of um a professional
services provider organization and a
corporate structure that has to be run
by and solely run by um members of that
profession and so um as you as you'll
hear it originally came out of a
Veterinary practice but it touches many
other type of um professional
organizations that that that have um
essentially
professional licensure and so you must
be um a member of that profession in
good standing basically to be a a a
director officer of of the organization
and it presents a problem only in the
situation of essentially a solo practice
PLC um they do exist um so there are
still solo practitioners more in some
professions than others um and The
Dilemma is if the um sole member and and
the corporate directors must all be
members of the profession uh suddenly
becomes unavailable and that can either
be because they died or um uh or they
lost their standing you know to practice
within their profession um then
essentially you're left with the
situation where yes this organization
does not currently have a professional
to carry out its duties but it also does
not have a director to to dispose of or
carry forward the organization if
they're more than one member then the
remaining you know professional is
authorized to continue operating the the
corporation uh but if you're the soul
member it falls into essentially a gray
area um
and it's dealt with in different ways by
different individuals some people sort
of form a handshake agreement with other
professionals that are not part of their
organization to sort of jump in at the
last minute if something goes wrong and
and you know essentially get appointed
by the court to take over and dissolve
the organization but what it amounts to
is it it essentially kills an otherwise
viable organization that could be um
continued in various ways you know by
bringing someone else on another
professional um or sold or um
you know at at least
uh something other than essentially
dissolution with no value because the
corporation is essentially unable to
operate and so this fixes that by
allowing um a a unique status which is
the uh uh appointment of what's called
an assistant manager um that is not a
professional is not a member of the
association but only in the instance of
a solo practice pllc can be
um in the position that if that person
becomes unqualified or or no longer
qualified for whatever reason that
person can step in and continue the
corporate directing the corporate side
of the pllc so that it can take whatever
actions it needs to including even you
know paying people and and other other
other things that would no longer be
possible
so um it allows that person to take that
status for uh a maximum of one year so
doesn't create a continuing uh situation
and the amendment clarified although it
it seems to be covered by the the term
qualified individual but that person
cannot carry out any professional duties
so if it's a Veterinary practice they
can't treat animals if it's a law
practice they can't you know advise
clients or manage their their funds or
anything so you know in order for it to
do anything other than essentially
dissolve a little more gracefully than
it would have other otherwise um they
would have to take some action to get
services from uh another individual to
basically take over that that Institute
so that that's the change um that's
proposed and um you know the the goal
again is is to preserve the value and
the utility and the uh of the
organization going forward without sort
of creating this kind of crisis
situation for you know for the the
entities running it and with that um
witness beinging none all right thank
Mr chairman members of the committee
thanks for the opportunity to testify
today my name is Roger gown my wife Dr
Jody Kaufman is a retired veterinarian
want to practice an exitor for 28 years
HP 98 addresses a problem with
succession planning for small
professional practices like my wife's in
New Hampshire in a single member limited
liability company or professional
limited liability company that has an
owner manager but no assistant manager
when the manager dies the executive of
the estate must petition the probate
court for an order appointing a person
to administer the practice winding it up
and dissolving it or selling it it can
take several months to get such an order
from the Probate Court during that time
with no one to manage the business it's
likely to lose much of its value however
if the LC or PC has an assistant manager
that person can immediately step in and
manage the practice under present law in
order to designate someone as the
assistant manager of a PLC that person
must be licensed in the profession of
the plc
in our case although I managed the
finances of my wife's business for many
years I was not eligible to be named
assistant manager because I am not a
veterinarian in the event of her death I
would have no authority over her
business even as the executive of her
estate I could not pay employees or
vendors I are a leaf veterinarian to
keep the business going convert the
business to an LLC or work to wind it up
or sell it under present law the
licensed professional pllc owner must
identify
another licensed professional that they
have the utmost trust in one who is
willing to take on such a large
responsibility simply as a favor this is
not an easy task for the owner of a
small single member practice and it
isn't always
possible HB 98 would make it easier for
owner managers to designate an assistant
manager as that person would not need to
be licensed within the profession this
person could be the licens professional
spouse or other trusted family member of
course the nonprofessional assistant
manager would have a limited time in
which to act would not be permitted to
work in the practice in a professional
capacity and would have to act in
accordance with the plc's operating
agreement HP 98 would help ensure that
the interests and desires of the owner
of a small professional practice would
be kept Paramount in the resolution of
the business thank you for your
consideration I look forward answering
your
sir is there anyone else uh who wishes
to uh testify regarding HB
98 seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing on HB 98 and we're a little bit
early to start the hearing on hb11 so
will as I understand it and as I believe
in it we talk
fine okay oh no you're we'll get I hope
we'll the other hearing will not take us
uh over
right easy G hours right right exactly
exactly
I don't understand the build let alone
his
testimony
e
it being 2:00 I'm open the hearing on
House Bill 111 and I'm going to
recognize uh representative Lynn to
introduce the Bill thank you Mr chair
and members of the committee um I'm here
to uh
introduce
hb11 which is um it's a it's a very
simple bill it simply
extends the life of the um right to know
on budsman which under current law will
expire on June 30th of this year to for
another two years um
uh I I did this after speaking with um
the um
budsman um who informed me of that I
until he had informed me I frankly
wasn't aware that it that the uh statute
had a uh that the the establishment of
the um budsman had a a cut off period um
I should say that um just being
completely candid when I introduced the
bill I thought this you know this
nothing there's nothing controversial
about this whatsoever we're going to
extend the the the Ombudsman was
established uh couple of years ago uh
maybe maybe three years ago now maybe
more but certainly very recently and it
just seemed to me that um it made it
made sense uh to give it at least two
more years to uh to see how it was
working out since that time I have been
told that some people have different
views about
the uh about whether having the the um
budsman is a good idea or not and I have
to say honestly that I that is something
that um I guess I would want to and I
hope that you will want to hear more
information on the on that issue because
I had not um as I said I sort of thought
that this was just completely not
non-controversial we were extending it
for two years and that was kind of the
end of it but if there are uh concerns
then you know I want to hear them just
as much as I think you would want to
hear them um and I guess I the other
thing I would say is this is something
is candidly um I have not discussed this
issue with the leadership of my party
and I don't know whether those of you on
the other side have discuss the issue
with the leadership of your party as to
knowing what you know what leadership on
either side thinks about about this and
that again would obviously that would
make a difference to me and I assume it
would uh it would make a difference to
the people on the on the other side so
that's kind of I introduced the bill and
um uh I think we I hope I hope you will
uh listen to the other witnesses that
are here um and you know we'll have a
chance to get some further input um all
around before we um exec this bill which
certainly which will not be today and
other than that I'm happy to answer
um I received as I think all of us did a
very thoughtful careful letter um
expressing concern and I read
it and um it was from someone in from
Rochester in straford County where I
live and there was nothing in that
letter that was critical in any way
of the Ombudsman or the office of the
Ombudsman it was critical of the way a
particular City in this case
Rochester um had behaved and
um is that the kind of complaint that
you are referring to no no I you're
right I did see that letter and I agree
with you completely that was not in any
way being critical of the udman it was
way particular people in Rochester had
had uh handle that so no that that was
not it but I have
heard uh some
grumblings from uh people including
including other reps um about uh you
know whether it's really worth having um
the um the udman or whether it would be
better to just not continue that and you
know go back to the old process of going
to Superior Court the only thing I would
say there is I think it's important to
keep this in
mind if it turned out to be the
conclusion of the legislature that we
should not continue the um budsman um
bear in mind we would have to make some
changes uh to some other
laws uh or at least other aspects of the
right to no law including for example
one that we just passed last year which
says that um you know we we we allowed
costs to be
obtained uh by municipalities for if if
there was an excessive number of email
requests and there's a provision in that
legislation that
requires uh that that uh provides for
the Ombudsman to
review uh certain certain aspects of
that so if we were to eliminate the um
budsman I think we would at the very
least have to make some changes to
um to that statute to say you know that
function would be performed Again by I
guess by the Superior Court um so any
anyway I'm just saying that you know
there may
be just eliminating the udman if that
was the anybody's intent might not be
quite that simple and I'm not again I'm
not suggesting that we should or should
not I'm I'm sort of open to to hearing
further discussion on this could I ask
one followup yes follow up thank you
very much
um Mr chair I believe that the work of
the
legislature is done in committee that's
why I think it's incredibly important
that every member of the legislature
serve on a committee because we all know
that's where the hard the heavy lifting
takes place so I would like to just ask
you so do you really
believe that a committee should
begin by listening to a directive from
leadership from people who aren't on the
committee that's doing the heavy lifting
no I guess what I was saying when you
say listen to I mean if
the I would want if leadership on either
side I mean my party from my side and
your party from your side said you know
we have a view knew that it's important
to keep the the ombudsman's office in
place on the one hand or it's important
to get rid of it on the other hand I
mean that would have significant impact
on me I guess I would want to you know I
would certainly be asking the question
why do you have the view you have but it
would be something that would be
important to me in my in my thinking on
the matter thank you very
much there any any other questions of
this
Witness representative
andas thank you Mr Vice chair and thank
you for taking my question Mr chair is
there data
available as to how many cases have
actually gone in how many has been
settled and what the total cost it is to
run that office I believe that that
information is available and that I uh
it may be that one of the witnesses
who's going to testify after after me
has that information I will say that um
I have met in the I well I think it was
in during the summer that I met with the
um budsman and he had you know a pretty
good list of how many cases he had had
heard uh that kind of thing he had a
pretty good bit of of of information and
I assume he's you know he still has that
and it's probably updated so I think I
think the short answer to your question
is yes that information is available
thank you
representative TR yeah thanks um and
thanks for the question um and it maybe
sort of Builds on the last two things
and even your opening statement I'm
curious about the the logic of just
extending it for two years um versus
removing the sunset provision you know
and saying if if at some point down the
line we think this is not worth it or
whatever that we would would act to um
to terminate the UN budsman
affirmatively um and and it sort of ties
to the question of what the metrics are
that we're that we or the legislature as
a whole are going to look to to see
whether or not this is or isn't in in a
couple of years functional and I think
the ones that that um representative
Andress mentioned are a couple that I I
think probably fit in there but I didn't
know if there was any thinking about why
why an extension is is still sort of on
a trial basis when it's kind of tied
into a number of other functions that
seem to fit well there yeah no thank you
for the question I um I think I mean you
you rais a good point I think you know
my my thinking in uh in putting it in to
extend it for another two years was that
it
was relatively
new um and you know we didn't have a lot
of information about how it uh was was
working um that my you know I met when I
met with the uh with uh the EMB budsman
I was you know I I thought he made a
very good presentation I thought you
know it seemed to me that he um he was
doing his job as he thought he should be
doing it um but I also my basic reason
for not sort of saying let's make it
permanent was it was new and I just
thought it made more sense to you know
extend it for a set period of time and
then maybe after that period of time if
you know it would make sense to make it
permanent but I I but I hear what you're
saying and you you you know that you
raise a a valid point
any other
questions seeing none thank you
representative Bergeron
yes thank you Mr chair so how's it going
at this point with the Ombudsman is
would this be more overwhelming would
this be do we hire more
or how's the office working well I what
I what I would say is and I think you
you want to hear from the udman you know
who will give you more detailed
information but that's a good point but
my my understanding is that the udman
has been very busy and has worked you
know and has and I think has had a lot
to do uh over the time that he's been
the utsman one of the things that I that
I think it's important to understand and
I think he'll tell you this is the
office of the right to know amb budsman
is him that's it so when I met with him
his office was in the basement of the uh
uh
uh State House Annex Building um not not
what we would call Lush Quarters at all
and literally I mean he he does all the
work when stuff has to go out he mails
it out or emails it out or does all that
stuff it's not like you know my my
assistant is going to handle this or
handle that um there is no assistant he
does it all um and so you know one of
the things that I think we have to think
about is
it may it may as a practical
matter uh if if this position is going
to be ex if the position is going to go
on it may be that there needs to be
additional resources and the fact that
there needs to be additional resources
may be may be something that goes into
the question of whether it's
worth extending the office because you
know it's it in some sense this is an
alternative to the superior
court is it a better alternative is it
not I I think we you know it's something
we ought to we ought to think think
about and I don't have a really a
that representative strip uh thank you I
uh it seems that you you've uh you've
imped that uh uh the edsman is going to
testify will he will someone from his
office be here today I believe I believe
I believe he is seem seems like he could
answer a lot of the
questions yes and I'm sure he will I
mean he's be when I met with him he was
very diligent in providing information I
that any other questions oh staying none
thank you I have one more I'm sorry
representative Bron I just wanted to
know that if we didn't do this and then
we had more people going in the court
system which one do you which one would
you prefer for our
constituents I know how to answer well I
mean the court system if if a case goes
to court then the court system has more
reason you know there's not the judges
have staff and you know that that kind
of so the court system has more
resources on the other hand I think it
is
it is certainly true that if we didn't
have the udman all of the cases that are
now being handled by the udman would go
to the court and so the court would have
more you know would have more to do so
it's uh I think that there's
no to me the udman certainly does defer
some cases that would otherwise go to
court even though it's true that there
can still be an appeal from the udman to
court um so and it's just him right now
just literally just him and unless
unless uh he's gotten better offices
since I talk with him he's in the
basement of the state housee Annex just
one more followup sir last one just I'll
just I'll just hurry so at this point do
you think that this General I guess I
could just ask him if he would benefit
from an additional person whether it' be
an assistant you could do
that you can well I mean if we're not
doing one should we make the other one
you know if there's even any areas of
inefficiency or maybe not but you
probably want help but thank you sir so
I just just as an side I think I
mentioned when I met with the udman that
I he's in the basement and I believe I'm
not sure about that I don't think
there's any windows but I think because
I think I remember saying to him you
know when I was when I first started out
as a judge they had me in the basement
of the Superior Court in Manchester and
there were no windows in the basement so
I got a picture that I hung on the wall
of a of a window
and that was my window and I was
thinking maybe i' give it to him for uh
for his
office all right thank you any other
kab would you think that it would be C
if the if say we weren't to pass this
bill would you think that it would be
cost prohibitive for some
to enforce right to no type cases if if
we weren't to pass this because the
filing fee if if I remember correctly
is$ 28 in Superior Court versus it's
only $25 with the EMB budsman do you do
you perceive that to be a potential
issue for for parties that maybe you
might not be able to afford that fee oh
yeah no I mean there there I think
there's no question that that's true
there I there are Provisions generally
in the suprior court rules you know to
wave the fees uh this discretion to wave
the KE the fees in certain in certain
cases if a person can't afford uh and I
think I assume that those would apply to
these kind of cases is um but but you're
right I mean as a general proposition it
court now are there any more questions
that's it okay kidding thank you thank
you is it Thomas Kerr okay I'll ask can
[Laughter]
thank you for having me today my name is
Thomas K KR it's pronounced K but I go
by a lot of things um I'm happy to
answer some of your questions but I can
give you a little overview of my office
which I think is probably helpful to
know what's going on so I've got a
little bit information for you and see
what we can do so the officer of right
to know Ombudsman that's commonly known
as the RKO because right to know
Ombudsman is hard to say uh is an
independent executive branch state
agency and it was created by laws
2022 chapter 250 uh even though it was
created in uh 2022 it was first staffed
by me on January 27 2023 and it remains
staffed by me
today uh it's established with goals
that sometimes can be a little bit
competing providing the public with a
simpler less expensive and faster
alternative to the superior court and
resolving complaints under RSA 91a the
right to no law uh that's the sum and
substance of what I can do I can address
other matters just RSA 91a and I look at
everything for the lens of RSA 91a that
it's different than a court I mean
sometimes people have disputes that
involve a 91a dispute and I have to say
I'm sorry I can't do that I'm not a
court I can only address the 91a
issues uh I began taking inquiries
receiving cases almost immediately
meaning that I had to perform the
functions of the agency even when I was
establishing the agency and its
procedures
uh it's currently set by law to expire J
July 1st 20125 at which time my current
term of office will also expire unless
that's renewed by the governor executive
councel uh not surprisingly I support
House Bill uh 111 broadly I believe that
it generally takes more than two years
for an agency to create itself and then
determine whether it's been successful
oneman
operation um again I'm
my
my scope of functions is limited to RSA
91a and I have to on many occasions I
have to explain that to people what that
means uh spend a lot of time explaining
things uh I hear here cases involving
all levels of state and local government
that includes agencies of the state
itself cities towns counties school
districts other entities as of today my
office has received now I'm going to
have to use a word that I use inquiries
I have received
277 inquiries that is people contacting
me about all kinds of things of the 277
inquiries that I've received 77 to date
have became actual filed cases
43 of the inquiries became right to no
request to me um and or the substantial
equivalent and currently I've closed 47
matters and I have 29 matters open
there's a little bit of difference in
those numbers because some of my cases
been Consolidated there are procedural
things that kind of change the two
numbers I gave you but 77 cases to date
filed 47 open and uh 29 I'm sorry 47
close 29 open uh during the duration of
the office uh the time of filing the
final disposition varies greatly that
depends on the issues that are involved
in the case procedural matters like
someone wants an in camera review which
is me actually looking at a document
which might have been withheld or
redacted in order to determine whether
it should have been delivered uh what
types of motions the parties file
including requests for continuance
rescheduling proceedings which happens
quite often and to great extent uh the
duration of a case depends on the
willingness of the parties to engage in
the processes that I've
established you I have uh my oldest case
is from back in October of 2023 as a
parties that case are aware that matter
involved a plethora of procedural
matters and for my planning purposes I
maintain a narrative docket of each
cas's history and so that I can keep
track of what's going on occasionally I
make that available to the public in
general after I've made sure I no
spelling
errors uh the shortest period from
filing the conclusion on the case was an
expedited proceeding that that was uh
eight days from filing to done uh my
first case as I said was received almost
immediately after I took the OA office
my newest case was filed about a week
ago uh the number of cases I get a
fluctuated between 0 and 8 a month U of
which all of them require some immediate
mentioned by me and yes I am the only
person my office is administratively
attached to the Department of State for
administrative purposes only what that
means is that my payroll has run through
them uh I have some assistance in
actually posting things on my website I
actually do the content but the physical
posting is done by someone over there
other than that uh from beginning to end
that's me first thing I need to do in a
case is within 3 days I need to let the
respondent know that there's been a
claim against them so I do the photocopy
and send that out they have 20 days to
respond to that and between the 21st and
the 60th day I either can grant deny or
under RSA 541 a29 schedule an
adjudicated proceeding or and the preher
conference almost all my cases have a
prehearing conference and then the
adjudicated proceeding or at least a
prehearing conference which is held and
conquered uh and then perhaps we can
resolve things on motions or perhaps
need an adjudicate
proceeding uh I try to encourage at
prehearing conferences I try to
encourage the parties to talk with each
other uh I believe that that's sometimes
more effective in person and I encourage
them to speak with each other and see if
the matter could be informally resolved
between the parties without a full
Hearing in part I do that because RSA
838 provides that as a matter of State
policy uh except to the extent precluded
by law informal settlement of Matters by
nonadjudicated processes is encouraged
and I do the try to do that
encouragement at a prehearing
conference uh again uh my hearings are
routinely held in conquered where my
office is located although the my next
hearing is on Friday and that's in the
town of Grafton uh standard case I would
say generally takes uh few months from
beginning to end given some of the time
frames that are built into the statute
done at times
just the filing of a case motivates
parties to have a conversation and leads
to a speedy resolution between them by
having a talk about what's going on and
I times I think that the existence the
office itself sometime itself sometimes
results in uh willingness of parties to
discuss and POS potentially resolve
matters without the my actual
intervention so since I and since I deal
with contested cases which by definition
involve two sides and I'm and on which I
ultimately have to be the decision maker
I suspect at least 50% of those who deal
with my office will be dissatisfied with
the result um I'm lucky if I you know so
I do my best uh apart from handling
cases inquiries during the first period
of my operation I had to establish an
update of web presence uh there's a web
page now there more information about my
office there you can find that through
the Secretary of State's website
although is clearly identified as mine
not the Secretary of States uh
established I had to establish
operational rules through the process of
RSA 541a if some of you are familiar
with RSA 541a that is not a quick
process I had a number of uh voluntary
public hearings at which a fair number
of people showed up um so I adopted my
administrative rules those were based
upon the model rules for adjudicated
procedure established by Department of
Justice uh they were reviewed by the
office of legislative Services rules
unit they were finalized by my agency
after a lot of public comment hearings
they were approved without objection by
The Joint legislative committee on
administrative rules and they became
effective on May 20th 2024 so now my
rules are in effect since I'm a one man
outfit that uh faces potential
dissolution on July 1st or June 30th the
the rules unfortunately contain a
provision which I think is probably
unique the rules actually say and this
is in RKO 21802 and
03 that says what happens to my cases if
I die become incapacitated or if my
agency isn't around anymore so I wrote a
rule about my own
demise uh the rules also highlight uh
the ethical obligations that I'm subject
to I'm subject to a lot of different
ethical obligations being a state
employee being an attorney been an
attorney now for since 1986 over long
that is what's it 30 38 years uh the
existence of a provision about what
happen should I die highlights the
difficulty with having one man operation
uh as does the fact that I'm required by
ethical rules to recuse myself from a
case if I believe that that's in order I
had to do that on one occasion I had to
recuse myself because it did not feel as
though I should be sitting on it under
the standards and guidelines that are
applicable to me where does that leave
someone well it doesn't leave with the
offic the right to know on buman because
I can't sit on the case that kind of
highlights the difficulty with oneman
operation apart from all the stuff uh my
first annual report is due on February
15th it's due to this committee so I'll
be doing a annual report to you folks on
uh honor before the 15th I'm doing my
best to get it done ahead of time uh
that report goes to this committee
Senate
Judiciary uh Governor executive IL Chief
Justice Supreme Court chief justice
Superior
Court uh my workload that's entirely
dependent on whether a member of the
public has a dispute with the state
local County government that they can't
informally resolve and if they elect to
bring that matter to
me uh that's a general overview of my
office and yes I I am in the basement on
well I I'm told to call at the ground
floor uh it's I'm in the basement and I
I have half a window I have a window
that you can see the bottom part of cars
from
um and uh you're welcome to come by it's
room 12 down the bottom of State House
Annex uh I get plenty of
Walkins so that's a little overview of
my office and what can I answer for you
questions for this witness
representative
Horgan um we got a letter from the uh
everybody in the committee got a letter
from a citizen and um not to get too
much in the specifics of that case but
and that person I think may be
testifying soon but like they talked
about uh person talked about that they
uh sought assistance from a friend and
you you gave permission that friend
apparently was not you representan I'm
not sure I think you want to be careful
about asking him about specific case
okay but who who are you who are you
allowed to like have uh what the rules
like who who you're allowed to have
represent you represent you if you don't
feel confident uh pursuing the whole
thing by yourself and there's no
requirement in my office that anyone be
represented by an attorney that goes for
the town and that goes for other people
um I have in the in my administrative
rules I came up in rul making about
whether there should be some type of
limits on who can come in and who can't
come in that's been reserved uh there's
actually a sectionary rule that says
reserved of common representation
and that's in case it wants to come up
again I frankly have
not I have not seen the need to to do
that and and I also want to point out
that prohibiting representation by
anyone other than an attorney works for
both sides I have a good number of cases
where a municipality
is represented
by their Town Administrator or someone
else who's not the the attorney and
that's that's up to the people as far as
I'm concerned as to who they want to
have be the
representative and if they adhere to the
rules they adhere to the
kab thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question attorney Kerr would
you feel like since this is more
intended to be like a a citizen to
Citizen type of a resolution process
that perhaps it would be appropriate
if there was a like kind of a two-prong
piece where one if there was no
compensation um exchange for a friend
helping somebody out with with a with a
case like this there was no no
exchanging
of compensation of any kind that they be
exempt from potentially be considering
unauthorized practice of Law and then B
um if
the um if um the udman office although
they're
all all remedies available under RSA 91
A8 are available to the embud zman if
one piece of that was Exempted and that
piece would be um from awarding the
reimbursement of attorney fees
and the reason I asked that is because
it
seems as though and this is in more than
one case but it's kind of like a
retaliatory automatic filing where you
know the if there is an attorney
involved that attorney is claiming hey
if if you lose I'm going to have make
you have to pay the attorney fees so
it's kind of discouraging the citizen
from using the process what would you
think about that I haven't given a lot
of thought to that uh I've had I've had
cases where both sides have requested
sanctions sanctions sorry remedies under
RSA
918 um and
and and if someone doesn't have an
attorney then attorney's fees aren't
available um I don't think I can say
anything more than that at this
point I mean I and in regard to mention
of unauthorized practice of law I have
no that's not my jurisdiction my
jurisdiction is to say who can represent
people in front of
me other questions for this witness
is am I correct in saying that there is
no
requirement that either party be
represented by an
attorney and having someone there as a
friend of
either side does not mean in any way
that they are putting themselves forward
as an attorney
I don't want to make
because that kind of depends on the
facts of particular cases but I I I
can't answer that that's not my my
jurisdiction I all I can do is say I
have no prohibition on a person
representing another person if they are
not an attorney thank you other
questions for this representative
Kat thank you thank you for letting me
ask a question uh chairman lenon thank
you for taking uh one more question you
mentioned the the prehearing conference
which is informal and I guess just from
a procedural standpoint I was curious
I've noticed that in other states
sometimes the udman after just getting
the filing and getting you know
um an answer back from the respondent
they're able to quickly just say oh this
is really cut and dry you just you have
to give these records um and often times
that that'll just be you know an order
that's emailed 3 days later and the
parties don't even have to
appear is that something potentially
that your office would be able to do so
that that way everybody that comes out
wouldn't have to take a day out of work
to come in for a hearing or no that
happens in some cases I mean some cases
there is no prehearing conference
because the matters resolved prior to
the prehearing conference frequently
it's resolved by informal agreement
sometimes I've resolved cases on police
meetings they just say a motion to
dismiss for example no
reason ask for the case to be dismissed
if there's a reason to dismiss it it's
dismissed there's no preeran conference
uh or some can ask for a ruling in their
favor essentially a motion for summary
judgment there's no need to have a
pre-hearing conference I've had for exam
an expedited proceedings I know when
expedited proceedings I know because
some of those involve things like what I
I don't only do can you get records They
also do was that a proper meeting was
the notice of the meeting proper um
sometimes those have to would have to be
done a little bit more quickly because
that usually comes up right before a
meeting uh but not all my cases end up
with a prehearing conference they can
and the majority have but not all thank
you other questions for yes
representative trip thank you chair
thank you for taking my
question it it appears to me that uh uh
for us to judge whether to
extend the ulman's office by two years
uh using you know uh performance
criteria is is kind of uh useless since
you've only recently actually finally
got your office set up to where you're
uh you have a website and and you have
rules you know uh do you think
that those two conditions will improve
the uh performance of your web of your
uh
office I'm torn on how to answer that
because I think I'm doing just about as
well as I can under the circumstances
however it is clearer to people now than
it was when I started what I'm doing
originally I had to explain everything
about here's what's going to happen
here's what you're doing I still do that
to some extent but now I can say take a
look at the rules take a look at my
website and so forth so I think it's it
makes it much easier for participants in
the process I do things basically the
same way my rules were based upon
Justice 800 which basically sets up how
you do things and the things that were
open I Tred to explain in letters I
still try to do that individually each
case that comes in I first of all I
photocopy the complaint I find the I
actually locate which people in the
municipality are the ones that are
supposed to be notified under my rules
because those are specific people you
can't just send it to anybody in the
town it's usually two or three people uh
and then I do a cover letter that says
here's how the process generally goes
here's where you find my rules and so
forth so I think when you talk about
about that Improvement I think that
Improvement has already probably been
degree other questions representative
tur uh maybe somewhat related and and
maybe somewhat uh related to the
questions that I asked uh uh
representative Lynn as the sponsor um
assuming this passes and two years we or
some people that look like us find
ourselves back judging this again um do
you have a sense of what Metro tricks we
should use to determine the
effectiveness of your office I think you
I think that you could do things like
number of cases that were answered in ex
that were addressed inside the statutory
time periods and I believe that that's a
good
metric
um
how I'm kind of torn on what else
because you can't really have a
decision-based metric right because I'm
a neutral and you can't say well this
many times it went this way this many
times it went that way you can't really
do that you can really only do things
about how the process is working and if
the process
failed and I don't have another metric
for
that other questions so I guess I have a
question Mr K I'm wondering
what would you think
if suppose that that your position was
changed from not so much being another
adjudicator suppose we we change the
position to make you what I what I would
refer to as something I would think of
that I would think of when you talk to
and I'm talk of an udman in other words
suppose we made your position more like
the consumer advoc before the Pu so that
we said you don't get to decide anything
but somebody who thinks that a
municipality or or the state has not
treated them fairly with regard to the
rights of nolaw they can come to you and
if you think so too or if you think they
have a valid case then you'll represent
them before the court um you know for
free maybe free of charge or whatever
yeah that that has been suggested by
people that because the name says on
budsman they ought to be doing something
different however the statute doesn't
set it oh no I agree uh and I my office
could have that function but it couldn't
have that function with one person I you
could have potentially you could have
someone that performs that function in
the office but they would have to be
different from the function that the
person that decides the case right right
no I was just saying what what if we
instead of having both we just said that
your function the function of your
office would be not to decide cases but
to Advocate I I I leave that to the
determination of the
legislature all right other questions
for this witness seeing none thank you
very much sir thank
good afternoon Mr chairman committee um
I'd like to make judicial notice that in
the 25 years that I've been coming to
testify this is the first time I've ever
got a parking place right in front of
the door so I'm considering today a
me my name is Robert Beville and I'm a
resident of marac New Hampshire I'm here
in support of the house bill 111 to
extend the position of the right to know
on budsman for the additional two
years by trade I have been a 30-year IT
professional as a director of
infrastructure and process analysis I
have an engineering degree from the
University of Texas and several
professional certificates in networking
program management and data center
operations at the age of 50 I returned
to law school and graduated with honors
in
2016 during the summer of 2016 I turn I
interned for judge Robert Coretta of
Lawrence District courton Massachusetts
later I graduated in 2018 from suffk law
with letters of Distinction for two
masters of law degree in intellectual
property information technology law and
biotechnology and health laws I have
written several appellate and amicus
briefs on constitutional and disability
laws I recently completed the department
of educa at the Department of Education
commissioner Frank El's request a
parents guide to the special education
due process hearings and although I
don't act ly practice law I have
advocated for many parents and special
education students for 10 years it is
because of my involvement in the special
ed community that I made the
acquaintance of the Rochester native uh
of whom you received a letter who who
assisted me in the development of the
parents guide for the Department of
Education she relayed to me her personal
experiences with filing under the office
of the right to know Ombudsman and the
weaponization of the process that she
had experienced at the hands of the
Rochester City
attorney after reviewing her right to
know requests and the rules governing
the RKO I agreed to advocate for her for
no
compensation the attorney for the City
of Rochester immediately began
unscrupulous lawfare tactics against me
and the citizen in a complete abuse of
the process I was twice investigated by
the Attorney General's office for the
unauthorized practice of law even though
the rkr already ruled that this is not a
court but he has the authority of a
superior court judge on matters
involving RSA
91a in the case of Rochester school
department number one and two RKO 2023
27 it is still pending before the um
budsman as its longest running
case I am here in support of extending
the position of the right to know um
budsman but this enabling bill as
written does not go far enough to
empower the Ombudsman to do his job
efficiently
first the RKO needs additional staff at
least a shared office manager and a
pargal to assist with the overwhelming
case load of work second the um budsman
needs to be moved to a more respectable
office rather than the basement broom
closet in the Secretary of State's
office third the ombudsman's budget
request for the funding of a citizen's
guide to filing a right to no request
should be granted and fourth the
Ombudsman needs to be reminded that he
already has the authority under RSA 91a
7B
3f2 quote make any finding and order any
remedy to the same extent as provided by
the court under RSA
91a 8 unquote this includes one the
power to compel witness testimony and
two the power to investigate
administrative acts of agencies that the
Ombudsman has reason to believe may be
contrary to law unfair unreasonable
oppressive arbitrary B based on a
mistake of fact based on improper
irrelevant grounds supported by
inadequate statement of reasons
performed in an inefficient or
discourteous manner or otherwise
erroneous I would like to share with the
committee that Ombudsman attorney Thomas
car has done a phenomenal job despite
the huge workload the lack of resources
and the severe disrespect he has
received from the city attorney of
rochest yes it has been a bumpy start
yes it could be less litigious but that
require the um budman's ability to
restrain the lawfare tactics of the
towns and City legal representatives and
finally the RKO should continue to be a
citizen-friendly forum to ask for and
receive the public records of our
government without fear of Retribution
legal action or reprisals by our own
City governments for simply asking for
public documents thank you for your
attention to this matter please vote for
the bill questions for this
witness yes representative pet now is is
that written testimony that you can
submit to the committee thank you very
much other questions for this witness
seeing none thank you very much sir
thank you um next I'm going to call on
please good afternoon honorable
Judiciary Committee members my name is
Katherine coko I represent right to know
New Hampshire we are an all volunteer
grass SCS group of individuals concerned
with transparency and the effective
implementation of 91 our RSA 91a in
keeping with the spirit of public access
to public information we've been
involved in the formation of right to
know related legislation since
approximately 2012 including the
creation of the ombudsman's office we
have a very broad base of members and
interested participants who have real
world experience and are often very
often in very nuanced applications of
the right to know law right to know New
Hampshire strongly supports h
hb11 which reauthorizes the office of
the Ombudsman for an additional two
years as attorney care stated um I had
an informal conversation with him I had
some of the same data he's received
approximately 275 inquiries with 76
different respondents and had 43 cases
since the Inception of the office some
of those cases reflect Consolidated
inquiries some of those inquiries never
become cases so the counting is a little
bit difficult to follow I understand the
importance of this office is in its role
as an alternative to Superior Court a
less formal and less costly means for
requesters to get clarification on the
practices that public bodies use when
they are implementing the right to no
law and I can speak from meaningful
experience I have gone through both a
lengthy and very costly year year-long
right to no court process which is one
of the reasons I'm in the role I am now
and an adjudicative process with the
right to no Ombudsman even though the
ombudsman's office was still forming at
the time when I filed my complaint I
believe I was a second case third case
maybe something something right up on
the top of that list um the process
there was much simpler than the court
process that I had undergone the year
before also my Superior Court Judge
didn't seem to know or um particularly
dive into the Nuance of the right to no
law the RKO understands the right to no
law and its precedents and is able to
articul at those throughout the course
of the process as you go through it this
is an area of law where it is hard to
find both attorneys and judges who are
deep in the Weeds on the application of
91a but it is critically important as it
is the only statute guaranteeing access
to government information by a lay
person in my right to no case with the
RKO which I'm providing as an example
the town of Milford had held an
emergency meeting under RSA 91a the
reason for that emergency meeting must
be given in the minutes of the meeting
that is done in part to justify lack of
sufficient notice that's provided to the
public because an emergency meeting is
usually um 24 hours within 24 hours or
something like that the chair of the
board in that case decided that the
reason for the non-public meeting would
be given or the reason for the meeting
would be given in the non-public session
of the minutes therefore checking the
Box fulfilling the requirement as far as
he was concerned and the board was
concerned but not telling the public
what the reason was it Justified having
an emergency session without any
notification to the public I challenged
that decision and I won the reason for
the meeting must be publicly available
the RKO stressed that and the town was
required to revise their minutes
appropriately and include that this is a
very simple case and a type of action
that by itself would not have been
corrected if simply correcting that
required an entire court case there are
many examples that we at right to know
see when people call us and ask us
questions about actions that have been
taken they don't rise to the level of
needing to go through court but they
start to add up to create a lack of
transparency in the way that things are
done many towns take small actions like
these interpreting the statute as they
see it without any recourse to the
public other than that expensive court
case the ombudsman's office provides a
much needed alternative for course
correction and in my however in my case
and in others it is true public bodies
are bringing in legal counsel um
something that I didn't expect I think
the original ators of the ombudsman's
office anticipated it would be slightly
less formal they are bringing in legal
counsel and fighting procedural
Corrections using legal tactics that
weren't foreseen by the committee that
created the Office that's why you're
hearing some of this feedback
particularly about Rochester but it is
not unique to Rochester when I met um in
my pre-trial uh conference with the
ombudsman's office uh Town Council was
very clear with me that if I was not
willing to do a declaratory judgment
with the town of Milford meaning that we
both submit our arguments only in
writing and forego an oral hearing which
I was something I wanted to do anyway um
he would be pursuing attorney's cost for
me based on what he claimed were an
excessive number of requests to the town
of Milford now I'm in a role where I'm
fairly confident that I understand what
that threshold is and wasn't concerned
about that particular threat and went
ahead with a declaratory judgment but it
is something that um is held over the
heads of people who are inexperienced
with the system that the town is is
going to come after them for those fees
because they feel that they can get them
through the ombudsman's office in
addition to as an alternative to getting
them through
Court um it was not intended to be used
by attorneys but communities are
choosing to send their legal counsel and
then they are asking um why they have to
Shell out those costs I would encourage
you it sounds like most have read the
email testimony from right to no member
and Rochester resident Tracy wallbridge
about the situation that she encountered
in Rochester I do think that is very
unique that is not um what the majority
of the cases are like finally and
probably most significantly the RKO is
not resourced we would like to see them
receive resources that would provide him
with basic supplies administrative
support a support role that is qualified
to serve as an advocate um because he is
the person who is handling all of the
hearings he has to be impartial he
cannot discuss situations or give advice
so there is no one that an individual
can pick up the phone and call and say
hey I'm in this situation um what does
the law say about this what kind of
conversation should I be having with my
municipality I think there was some hope
the office would do that if he had
someone that he could bifurcate that
responsibility off to then the office
would be able to be of more assistance
in that way and finally um he has
mentioned the need for a users's guide I
think that would be extremely helpful
for people right now they're trying to
navigate using the administrative rules
that have been put together um we to
know New Hampshire did weigh in on those
uh but I do think that it would be
easier for someone to navigate if they
had a userfriendly document that could
guide them through the filing
process I will conclude my testimony
questions questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
representative thank you for allowing my
question uh Mr chairman and thank you
for taking taking my question
um could you elaborate a little bit more
on I guess what the biggest difficulties
that you've seen for those who are using
the udman office like are there you know
just I you talk to a lot of different
people throughout the day and what are
you hearing from those who are who are
in your organization I I think the
challenge is that they are not attorneys
so it is navigating a quasi legal
process um and understanding some of the
language that comes from the rco's
office um he's very clear in his
Communications about what is needed but
it's in a very structured way that most
people aren't used to communicating in
um so I think I think that's the biggest
challenge and that if we could simplify
that in some way that would be great I
would not like to see the need for that
become a barrier to continuing the
office the office is providing a service
that has been tremendously helpful in
preventing people from needing to go to
court and then solving other resolving
cases that probably wouldn't otherwise
be
heard other questions for this witness
seeing none thank you very much thank
you very informative now
next the person's first name is Joe and
I assume that must be you but I'm not
quite sure the
sorry Joe Joe hot okay wow all right I
didn't
Haas good afternoon from
gilmington I put down one and a half
minutes okay then then that's then
that's the same card go ahead Mr H
welcome yeah I just wanted to say on the
past tense I I have taken a right to
know case in Ashlin uh back in the 1980s
to the Superior Court in Grafton County
and I won the case that was on trying to
get the town lease on a tax sale of my
property I cited a union leader uh case
on that and won it and I didn't get
attorney fees because I didn't hire an
attorney but I should have gotten
something I think so let me just tell
you what I put into the uh Belmont case
uh uh uh the previous speaker talk
talked about hearings and postings and
stuff like that I'm just talking about
documents that I want from this town and
some other places the common denominator
is out west kingcast Chris King I don't
know if you remember him he was used to
be in the state and filming Kelly aart
everywhere she goes and stuff but
anyways he found a case out there that I
cited in the Belmont case and it says
that uh the y upon the person
withholding the documents that are
supposed to be released within five
business
days for each day over that the $7 per
day per page charge is applicable and I
think in the statute he has the power to
find the opposition that uh did not
comply with the statute up to
$2,000 so my suggestion is perhaps you
could put in there that the litigant uh
the complainant uh could get get maybe
10% as a finder fee as as a
whistleblower uh amount to uh offset
their expenses all right any questions
for this witness thank you seeing none
thank you very much um next I'm going to
uh
Lori
good afternoon you got it
perfect um nice to see you all um couple
quick things so I did a quasi judicial
hearing with the btla when I first
started with uh issues with my property
I had the choice of going into Superior
Court or through the board of tax and
land appeal for my property appeal and
looking back having no experience at all
best decision I made was going to the
btla it's much less formal it's quasi
judicial it's a panel of three that do
land disputes all day every day and it
was easy uh the forms the office
interfacing it was easy now they're they
have more resources than attorney cor
ker in that there's two assistants and
the three members and I think one other
part-time person so they're resourced
pretty well but I will tell you looking
back I thought that was great and anyone
whoever calls me that is entering into a
property abatement appeal I always say
go to the btla cuz the courts are busy
they focus on all kinds of law they're
not specifically focused on land issues
you get this focused group and those
three individuals up there I thought
were very talented very knowledgeable
now regarding the court versus the um
budsman and I'm here representing right
to know New Hampshire as well as a
member and um I support this legislation
um I know there could be some amendments
to it but I'd like to see this office
keep going and have an opportunity to
develop a little more I think it's
extremely worthwhile and I have not used
the office for various reasons which
I'll explain but I think the UN budsman
office when it comes to costs clearly
it's less costly just from a filing
standpoint citizens have a much easier
ability to get in there on 25 bucks and
going into the um court system and
paying the 280 the other thing is the
the superior court system when you file
and you're wrapped into that turbo court
and odyssey system for filing it's
pretty darn dated it is difficult when
you're a citizen working through the
court process of getting your website
logging on filing the proper forms
following up it is really complicated it
is really hard um you have to call for
assistance often I don't think that I'm
a I'm a proos say l again I don't think
we're the the most liked people um
because we're time consuming cuz we
don't we don't get it you know and and
we're burdensome so when you go to an
office like Deon budsman where that's
pretty much all all they deal with or
the btla that's all they deal with
people like um individuals who are not
represented they have a lot of patience
for us and they have a lot Le less
complexity built in so I think the user
friendliness of the forms is very
important time the courts are busy I
think they're very understaffed they may
have staff like judges may have
assistance but I was shocked to learn in
Superior Court each judge doesn't have
their own personal assistant they share
them with other judges I was shocked
NASA only has two Superior Court judges
for a city and a jurisdiction that is as
large as it is in the past there were
three or four there's only two they are
so busy and so you know RSA 91a afford
you a priority hearing expedited they
don't have time
they have an administrative rule called
AO 201308 they don't really have an
opportunity to follow it so my first
right to know case took two and a half
years I just came out of court with a
right to Noe case um last um year by
July that took a full two years to go
through Court that's a long time and
with that comes a lot of costs because
the other side when a city goes into
court they're not sending in their
administrator they're sending in a legal
team my last right to know they put five
lawyers against me it was a huge team I
was alone that whole case for 2 years
cost me maybe $115,000 of my own
expenses the city invested 600 Grand
paying two outside attorneys to try to
beat me on that case that's a lot of
money I I don't want to see that happen
to Citizens so I'm a big advocate of
this office when it comes to metrics
somebody mentioned metrics how do we
measure performance you know I think one
of the ways is isn't just time to
resolve but how many of those
municipalities use the lawyer to come in
and represent them and how many of those
citizens required a lawyer to to have
their case represented because if I
think I think if you can show that that
office is operating with less legal um
tentacles working its way in there then
you are doing a great job of really
making something citizen friendly and um
and trying to mediate and negotiate
something that's to the you know the
greater good of both parties you both
got to give something to get there you
know even when the court orders
mediation and you're in a judicial
process a lot of times I know twice
there was mediation ordered the judge
Cav six lawyers none of them were ever
available nobody's available so but I
think going through the um budsman
you're going to really have the
opportunity to mediate um
so you know in the idea that Justice
Lynn brought up on consumer Advocate and
then um you know making a a a using the
utsman to give a position and and then
being the individual to go into court
I'm not big on that because I just see
the burden in court um in and the tie
down and the cost and the demand on the
judges and the individual it's so
personally stressful to represent
yourself as a proa litigant in court I
cannot tell you how stressful it's been
I paid a quarter of a million dollars
for my first lawsuit and then after that
I filed on on my own I said never again
am I going through that and even on your
own I'm always up against three four
five lawyers it is so stressful and I
don't go to the udman office because I
happen to be in a city that like
Rochester I think is really difficult
and I was a very big advocate of the
utsman office and I didn't want that
gentleman to puncture both eardrums and
want to drive a pen through his eye
because NASA was coming to his office I
really didn't want to see that happen I
I wanted n to stay away because I felt
like what happened in Rochester would be
exactly what NASA would do up there and
I did not want that to happen so anyone
in NASA that has issues I don't
encourage them to go to the utsman but
towns outside and through my right to
know work I really do encourage them to
go to the utsman make a go of it so I
think I think we want to invest in this
I would like to see like um attorney
Belleville and Miss coko recommended
some pargal assistant or somebody even
it's part-time halftime and I know this
budget is under the state is under
tremendous budget stress um but if it's
possible then I think it would be super
beneficial if it isn't then we give it a
go the way we're going and we accept
what we have um and and try to you know
get this user guide out and do a few
small things to drive Improvement and we
let it keep working I I'm I'm really a
proponent of that so I hope I'm I'm glad
to see the two years would mind seeing
it without 2 years and just roll and
monitor monitoring is important always
have a handle on the the efficiency of
of government so that's my input thank
you very much thank you questions for
this
we representative Manos thank you Mr
chair um I wanted to know uh whether in
your view the edsman currently lacks the
safeguards necessary to protect
individuals from retaliatory actions by
by municipalities or agencies and if you
do agree with that what um additional
safeguards would you say are
necessary well I would say I do agree
with that just because it wasn't
necessarily foreseen when the
administrative rules were put in place
um I I I don't want to see lawyers have
open Reign to come in here and obviously
um take control of a process that's
supposed to be quasi judicial and really
be a mechanism for citizens to open
records and mediate I don't know how to
word that or make that happen I don't
think I can give you a a good answer off
the top of my head but I do think it can
happen and I do think it h I think I
think in Tracy wri's case it did happen
and we don't want that to happen and
that may be an outlier but it can happen
it's I believe it would happen in nasua
which is why I won't go there I will not
in take that mess to a gentleman's
office that is run by one person I just
don't want to do it other questions for
this
witness seeing seeing none thank you
very much thank you is there anyone else
who wishes to testify on uh HB
111 uh
FN oh yes Miss Miss K if you come up
please
good afternoon Aon crean general counsel
for the court system uh making a very
rough effort to get some data for you
just for your
consideration um we did a little um
manual count spot count through the past
year and it does look like we have had a
substantial decline in right to no
filings in the Superior Court System
since the implementation of this bill um
I think our based on an anecdotal sample
of Clerks it looks like around 40 to 40
45 cases a year were filed and that may
be in our spot check below 10 in the
last year which is a it's not a very
large and and popular case type but it
is a substantial decline percentage wise
certainly um so I did want to mention
that to you for your awareness it does
seem that um many are choosing to
participate in the right the Ombudsman
process as opposed to go to Superior
option that that is that's very helpful
question for this witness yes
representative
kab thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for taking my question do you know
approximately how many of those 10 might
have been cases that were being appealed
from the um abun office it looks like
it's under five thank
you other questions for this witness
seeing none thank you very much thank
you
all right anyone else who wishes to be
heard on U hb11
FN seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing uh on hb11 FN and I'm going to
open the hearing on
hr6 and I'm going to recog recognize one
of the co-sponsors of the bill
representative Perez thank you thank you
Mr chairman thank you committee I'm
going to be very brief because Caitlyn's
going to take over for me but um this
this bill is condemning the judicial
doctrine of desperate impact and you
have a letter in hand which Caitlyn's
going to go over with you a little bit
but I want to tell you how I ended up
getting involved in this first of all I
had to look up the definition and um
desperate desper desperate impact uh
also is considered adverse impact
commonly refers to
unintentional discrimin atory PR
practice and that's the key word here is
that it is unintentional
discriminatory um practice and the
reason why and and after Caitlyn reads
this you'll know a little bit more but
the reason why I ended up supporting
this with um representative Belcher is
because I used he approached me about a
um law enforcement case where it was and
he refers generally to to it that there
was um in an area of um people of color
uh poorly educated um graduating from
high school um unable to be uh read and
write at an appropriate level and they
someone applied to a um police
department and part of the requirements
is that you had to fill out the
forms and they were um un able to fill
out the fs forms because of their lack
of um education and it's ended up going
to court and I believe it is still in
court so they filed that they felt that
the practice of remember I'm a nurse not
a lawyer um the practice this practice
meant that they had a their policy of
having to read and write these things
was uh discriminating against them
because they were people of
color I have a concern about another way
that that may have happened in the long
past and I'm talking probably 30 or 40
years ago having had two firefighter um
firefighters in my family um there were
certain rules around being a firefighter
I can remember one specifically is you
had to be able to carry 110 pound person
out of a out of a burning building the
other one was at that time that you had
to be able to uh you had to have a
physical every year and part of that
physical was to make sure that you were
able to do certain requirements of the
job being for example hook up the hose
in a certain amount of time or that type
of thing and unfortunately back then um
women said that they were being
discriminated
against um under this type of it was an
inv totally
involuntary they they the reasons for
these things that they required for this
position were for the safety of the
individuals and the safety of the
community so basically they ended up
because of this lowering the standards
for the fire department or for in order
to allow women to be part of it so I'm
going to let them read it this came
actually came up in some hearings the
same type of thing came up in some
hearings yesterday um at the Senate so
I'm going to let her read this to you
please Caitlyn and I apologize that I
have to leave um and of course
representative um
belur wife is in labor so I'll take a
quick question but you're probably
better off to have Caitlyn read it and
we can probably discuss it more after
other people talk discuss it more in
executive session sure uh any qu briefly
questions for representative Perez
representative Oregan do you have a
question well maybe this wait for the
executive session but I just notice the
last line he wants to transmit it to the
president of United States who's not
mentioned by name the president's
changed since he filed it the members of
the ire Congressional I'm sorry where
are you oh on the actual resolution
itself on line 1
and he named honorable Chris senu the
governor who's now no longer the
governor so uh would you prefer I guess
the exective session address the issue
of how to how he should reward it
whether just be the governor of New the
state of New Hampshire whether they want
name amended at that time so rep
representative bur but make it quick
okay please thank you yes thank you and
thank you for taking my question uh you
use the term unintentional which I don't
understand stand to be part of disperate
uh impact law could you excuse me I'm
sorry my question is could you identify
either where in the Griggs case or in
section 703 of the Civil Rights Act is
the word
unintentional no I can't and I apologize
as I say and if you read what um
representative belter put forward you
can see that he is far more informed and
literate about this particular case
thank you okay all right thank you other
question no thank you very much thank
all right um representative kab do you
have in the interest of time does
everybody want me to read this whole
thing or does every would everybody
prefer to read this on their own I think
we've read I've I've read it so read it
okay everybody said okay perfect all
right so uh next uh um max
Gard afternoon um I'm here to testify in
opposition to this bill um disperate
impact is a judicial doctrine that has
been recognized for decades as um going
back as far as the Civil Rights Act um
but as recently um as the Supreme Court
decision um Texas Department of Housing
and Community Affairs versus inclusive
communities project Incorporated um a
Supreme Court case in
2015 um specifically intended to include
um and allow uh disperate impact claims
um so first I think it's strange that
New Hampshire is you know seeking
through a house resolution to overturn
uh judicial doctrines recognized by the
Supreme Court um
I'm obviously not a lawyer so I don't
understand if a state can overturn
National Judiciary doctrines like that
in the first place um but I think it's
uh ridiculous to uh be overturning the
the idea that a rule if a rule on its
face seems to apply equally but then the
outcome is not equal um
such as the rules that were placed on
African-Americans in order to vote uh
before the 1964 Civil Rights Act um
which were constructed in a way to
appear on its face to be an equal rule
but in practice was uh quite
discriminatory and that is what the idea
of disperate impact as a general
principle is trying to address um I have
additional concerns about the actual
wording in the bill um the first
sentence of the bill is whereas the
practice of
unit analysis for complex real world
phenomena is illegitimate and
unscientific um which univer analysis is
looking at a problem in terms of one
variable at a time which anyone who's
gone through like you know High School
science
um is a valid scientific method anyone
who's done like you know a Cen Mentos
experiment uh can know that looking at
one variable at a time is a valid
scientific method um does it uh is
should all problems always be viewed
through one variable at a time obviously
not but to say unilaterally that the
practice of univariate analysis for
complex real word phenomena is
illegitimate and
unscientific uh I think is just
going a step so far removed from reality
um uh it then goes on to say that that
uh univariate analysis produces
conclusions such as thing one happened
then thing to happened therefore the
first thing was causitive of the second
thing um I think it's a dangerous idea
to uh attack
causality um as a thing that can be
known obviously that thing one happened
and then thing two happened it is not in
this little individual sentence here um
it's not uh impossible that thing one
wasn't caused by didn't cause thing two
but to say that thing one happened then
thing two happened therefore the thing
first thing was causitive is just an
illogical
construction um used to then just ify
throwing out a decades long legal
doctrine that uh tries to address
discrimination in this country I'd love
to answer any questions questions for
this
witness
represent anyone have any questions
seeing none thank you very much sir
thank you right is there anyone else who
wishes to testify on uh
hr6 right seeing none I'm going to close
the hearing on HR six um and I think uh
basically we're done um I just just so
that I
I've my caucus is aware of this and your
ranking member is aware of this but just
to let everyone know um what I've told
them there's been a change in plan since
first thing this morning and the change
is that in addition to the other
hearings that um I've already scheduled
for the 22nd and the
29th we will we will be having a hearing
on Monday January 27th at
9:30 on um the uh I believe the only
abortion bill um that um is going to
come before uh come before us and let me
get the number here uh what is it
476 HB
uh which is I'm I'm referring to
colloquy as a 15we um abortion bill so
we will um we will be having a hearing
on that uh probably in rep's hall
because I think we're I'm not positive
on that yet but I think that's where
it'll be and then we will be executing
that bill uh when we're done with the
hearing um so I want everybody to know
that that's uh that's what uh that's
what's going to be happening on the 27th
um all right and with that
um uh yeah so so you know and I should
say that just as I just to follow up so
people don't since we're going to be
executing that day if for some reason
you can't be here that day if you're in
the Republican party please let me know
so I can get a substitute and if you're
in the Democratic party please let
representative Smith know so she can get
a substitute U and with that have a good
evening and thank you all thank you all
it's great meeting the new reps and uh
um I look forward to working with all of